we were a team despite our differences
in spite of the Terrible Things they'd
done we were still a team
that's not how the higher-up saw it
though
the guys upstairs with their perfectly
pressed shirts for them we were judged
by our level of expendability and they
knew that our next mission was a death
sentence one by one that thing took out
my team my friends
snapping their necks so quickly and with
such ease that no sooner did I hear the
scream
they were dead
we had been used
I'd been used
delivered as prey to the Predator a plot
that was sanctioned by the bosses and
approved with a blood red stamp
why did they do it
I'm still trying to figure that out
maybe that's something you can tell me
after you hear how these so-called
scientific men left us in the cell
and in the hands of SCP-173
for me it had been the best of times
before it became the worst of times
the best because I'd quickly risen
through the ranks of the facility
the worst because well
I was never the best student I finished
high school by the skin of my teeth and
my job prospects looked Bleak but I was
lucky I guess
or at least I thought so at the time
you see I have an uncle Siegfried who
did some work for the government I never
actually knew what he did just thought
it was secretive work
I used to imagine he was some sort of
super spy so you can imagine how excited
I was when he found out I needed a job
and he offered to help me out
I couldn't believe it I always thought
he hated me
and overheard him telling my parents
that I was a no-good deadbeat but now
he'd have a change of heart and was
willing to take me under his wing
but what would I get to do undercover
intelligence gathering
International assassinations
just you wait he said
and that's how I found myself walking
into a sprawling futuristic looking
facility where they handed me a level
one security clearance card with big
bold letters that read
janitor but I was happy just the word
security clearance made me feel
important and it beat flipping burgers
I push mops turned off lights fired up
generators clocked in and clocked out
but all that time they must have been
watching me grooming me waiting for the
day they could throw me to the wolves
I should have known
I've always been an Expendable kind of
guy after a few years I was called to an
office and there was a man in a plaid
shirt and kind of a tweed jacket that
professors wear
he asked me do you have any idea about
what we actually do here
and to be honest I didn't I knew that
there were many parts of the facility I
couldn't enter I imagine that down a
maze of corridors were weapons being
built with prisoners being interrogated
but I had no idea about the anomalies
how could I before I was told anything I
had to sign a bunch of forms there were
so many I thought I'd get to find out
who really killed JFK
and while they didn't come out and say
it what I inferred was that if I ever
talk about what happens at the facility
to someone outside the facility well
let's just say it's not the kind of
thing they'd spell out on a piece of
paper but it involves bad it sells and
Rusty tools
I wasn't scared though
I was part of something big
secret and I loved it so I signed my
life away with no hesitation soon after
I was introduced to my first anomaly the
safe class of course
it took me to an observation room from
that room I could see into another room
with a sign on the wall that read
scp-067 I just stood there waiting for
something to happen when in walked
another guy in a white platco welcome to
your first anomaly he said is it okay if
I hook you up to this heart monitor we
want to gauge your reaction to what you
see
all I can see I told him is an empty
room with a table in what looks like a
pen on top of some papers
correct he said half smiling as if I was
some kind of idiot that's
scp-067 I thought about telling him that
if I needed years of training before I
could see a pen that I probably should
have taken that fast food job could have
been a shift manager by now
then they brought a young chimpanzee
into the room small enough to be
harmless one of the guys forced to pen
into the scared shimp's hand and
something strange happened
started scribbling nonsense at first but
suddenly it was sketching and drawing
faster and faster I could catch glimpses
of words and images by the time they
dragged it out it was flailing around
like it was possessed that pen has power
said the man in the lab coat a power
whose Source or origin we don't fully
understand
that's why we're here that's why you are
here one of the guys in the other room
held The Chimps drawing up to the window
it was a perfect sketch of the Tower of
London intricate and brilliant
above the sketch was the title Tower of
London Tudor period Circa 1541 the year
Margaret Pohl the Countess of Salisbury
lost her head on The Chopping Block
underneath that the chimp had written
pity she was no traitor take it from me
I was there they didn't need to look at
the heart rate monitor to see that I was
shocked
that was far from the only anomaly I'd
come into contact with and I must have
been doing something right because in
time I went from Level 1 to 2 to level 3
security clearance and that's when they
made me a containment specialist I won't
bore you with all the details but as you
can guess I dealt with the containment
of anomalies a lot of my time was spent
looking through small windows and cell
doors making sure that whatever was
inside was still inside and still in one
piece
other times I worked with field agents
when anomalies were brought in a
transition period that the arrested
freaks didn't much like there was one
certain anomaly though that I was tasked
to oversee on many occasions I like to
think of it as my pet
but in hindsight I was its pet
this was
SCP-173 something that was in what we
call the Euclid class the classification
meaning that we don't fully understand
it but no it is very dangerous
we know it's intelligent we know it's
unpredictable and we know it will kill
and for that reason there's people
tasked with containing it and keeping an
eye on it at all times
at first glance you wouldn't guess just
how dangerous 173 is you wouldn't think
it's incredibly intelligent in fact
you'd think the opposite that's because
it's more or less a walking slab of
concrete and rebar with stunted Limbs
and traces of spray paint that give the
impression of a Dopey face we have to
enter itself twice a week for cleaning
duties it leaves a disgusting foul
smelling liquid on the floor a reddish
brown substance that I can only describe
as a mix of blood and waste products
where that stuff comes from has remained
a mystery since we first contained it in
1993.
going into the cell was always a
three-man job because and this is maybe
the weirdest part about 173. can't move
if human eyes are watching it that's why
you need at least two people watching it
at all times if you're in the room
watching 173 by yourself and blinked
you'd be dead before your eyes opened we
don't know how it moves that fast but in
that fraction of a second your neck is
snapped so hard it's almost like being
decapitated I've seen the videos to
prove it all it took was a sneeze he
wasn't even finished getting the rest of
the achoo out when there was a Flash and
his partner was left lying on the ground
his head twisted around the wrong
direction so you can understand why we
now require three men for any time we
must enter 173 South
then a few months ago I was told that a
long process would begin to train and
re-educate some future class D's class
D's are mostly prisoners with lifelong
sentences or those we've taken from
death row and given a new lease on life
we were apparently understaffed so why
not employ these men whose lives had
pretty much ended anyway that was the
rationale or at least that's what they
told me I was told to train them on
their new job mopping up 173's mess so
that me and the rest of the containment
specialist could focus on more important
tasks
they hadn't been through the training I
had seen what I had seen But after
showing them the video of 173 nearly
taking off a man's head they were more
than willing to follow the rules they
understood not to Blink or turn away or
sneeze and that any lapse in Focus could
lead to a violent death so I started to
show them the robes how we move as a
team into the cell and always keep the
others informed on what we're doing
173 was always sitting in the corner of
a cell no expression on that crude face
but when we walked in itself I got the
feeling it knew something had changed
I felt almost as if it was communicating
with me but I couldn't tell what it was
trying to say
then it happened
it was a Tuesday afternoon three days
from the last time we cleaned as usual
173 had covered the floor with that
horrible liquid we headed in to clean my
new team alert as always and some of
them cleaned While others kept their
eyes focused on the thing in the corner
things were going smoothly when we heard
a noise I knew very well
it was the sound of the cell door
locking
someone must have screwed up hey guys
we're locked in here I shot it through
the intercom
nothing guys the damn door is locked
nothing
I lost it a bit open the door will you
my team looked at me the ones not on eye
contact Duty that is as if I should know
what to do hoping that this had happened
before and that there was some kind of
standard plan to deal with it there
wasn't
we were always observed when in the room
and I knew that a technician couldn't
accidentally lock the door it was
impossible there were protocols someone
had done this on purpose
the four of us sat in the corner of the
room as far from 173 as possible our
eyes locked on it it didn't move an inch
as usual just stood staring at the wall
as it always did
we stayed awake through the night
talking a little holding on to the slim
hope that something had gone wrong
but as night turned today again we all
began to lose hope we weren't sent here
to clean we were a test totally
expendable
Lab Rats but I wouldn't go down without
a fight we couldn't just stay up forever
that was a death sentence I suggested
that two of us stand one sit and rest
and one get some sleep
we take shifts a couple hours on a
couple hours off
maybe we could show that we wouldn't
give up they'd have time to realize what
they were doing was insane call off the
test and come free us
we made it through a couple of shifts
like this and it seemed like we'd
actually be able to make it another day
or two when everything went wrong
it was my turn to sit and rest when I
heard the worst possible noise
snoring
the con next to me was sleeping quietly
so it must be one of the standards I
glanced over for just a split second and
saw both of them leaning against the
cell wall dozing at the same time I saw
the flash crack snap pop one after
another their necks were snapped I'm not
sure how it happened but I was standing
again staring at 173 who was now in the
corner dead bodies with their heads
twisted around piled up in front of it
I couldn't take it anymore I couldn't
stare at this thing forever I felt
myself giving up I lowered my head to
the ground and then finally broke my
gaze ready to die
and then
nothing happened I slowly raised my head
back up and there it was its hideous
face inches away from mine it was then
that I understood what we'd been
containing but we'd underestimated
I felt it again like it was telling me
something
was telling me to close my eyes
sleep
so I did but as my eyes closed I didn't
see Darkness I saw 173 or something like
it but not in the cell
I saw it outside in the world standing
over children sleeping in the beds
watching
I saw them hiding in the shadows
staring out at passersby
and I realized they weren't watching
waiting to pounce
no they were hiding my eyes popped open
as the door opened and in Rush Six
security personnel
they took me outside jabbed my leg with
a syringe injecting me with something as
the world faded
away
incident report time and date redacted
following the experimental forced
interaction with Euclid class anomaly
SCP-173
subject has ceased responding to
external stimuli and appears to have
taken on the traits and behaviors of the
anomaly subject now spends entire day
sitting in corner of cell staring at the
wall
staff are advised to proceed with
caution when dealing with subject as the
only Behavior they engage in is an
attempt to strangle anyone who enters
the cell no treatments have shown any
Effectiveness and subject will
unfortunately require incarceration
likely forever
SCP-173 it's one of the most iconic
anomalies ever contained by the SCP
Foundation this next snapping site-19
celebrity is known and feared by
everyone who works at the foundation
since being contained in 1993. its nubby
concrete hands metaphorically and quite
literally stained with the blood of
countless people but this mostly
immobile Oddity wasn't always a resident
of site 19 and the story of how exactly
it ended up there and more importantly
why is far more ridiculous insane and
downright terrifying than you could ever
imagine so buckle up SCP fans this is
the dramatic tale of how this homicidal
piece of Modern Art ended up at the SCP
foundation's largest containment site to
give United of just how weird this
origin story is we're gonna have to leap
forward to the year of 2045. we know
what you're thinking isn't this a
prequel how can it take place in the
future sit tight folks it'll all make
sense in the end sight 91 is where we
lay our scene under the watchful eyes of
site director Dr James long a senior
researcher with level 4 security
clearance the second highest at the
foundation Dr long had given Decades of
devotion and his expertise to the
foundation he was a proud man who wore
his life of service to the containment
cause as a badge of honor after years of
dodging death while researching some of
the most dangerous anomalies that site
91 had to offer he had ascended to the
rank of site director which represented
the culmination of his life's work and
in his new position of power he'd only
proved himself further running a tight
ship and reducing the number of
containment breaches across the board
nobody could say that Dr long was an
extremely talented at his job which is
why he was so confused when he received
an email from Alexandra Nala an
administrative assistant working
directly for the o5 council it was the
type of email that no site director ever
wanted to receive Dr long was being told
backed with no input or oversight from
him the majority of site-91's anomalies
were going to be taken to an undisclosed
location for safer containment the list
contained nearly every meaningful
detainee contained on the site including
of course as cp173 this particular
anomaly had been contained at the site
for 37 years after being delivered there
in 2008. Dr long had devised a perfect
method to minimize containment breaches
in that time creating a sprinkler system
within the chamber that washes away the
waste products produced by 173 reducing
the need for risky human contact but
that didn't matter despite Dr Long's
loyalty and efficacy in serving the SCP
Foundation the decision had already been
made with no chance chance of reversing
it according to Nala the motion to
remove most of site-91's anomalies had
received unanimous approval from the o5
council and the operations for the
transfer would be commandeered by the
department of extra Universal Affairs
headed by senior agent Sven Kish Dr long
was both upset and confused he was
producing some of the best results
across the entire foundation so why were
they taking away all of his anomalies
did someone on the yo 5 Council have it
out for him Dr Long replied to Nala
asking if considering how severe the
relocation operation was going to be
whether he could get more information on
where the anomalies were being moved to
and why he felt that at the very least
he was owed some answers on this Nala
and her superiors didn't feel quite the
same way she replied that Dr Long sadly
didn't have the clearance to know any of
the operations particulars this
information was reserved for those with
level 5 clearance and members of the
multi-universal department all that Dr
Long needed to do was stay out of the
way and everything would be taken care
of for him but that wasn't enough for Dr
long he needed to know more he needed to
understand why this seemingly random
decision had been made realizing that
Nala and the o5 council were a dead end
as far as information was concerned he
instead reached out to the next best
thing senior agents Fen Kish the member
of the Department of extra Universal
Affairs who was spearheading the
relocation Mission Dr Long implored the
agent to give him extra information on
where all the site-91 anomalies were
being moved and why they were being
moved in the first place predictably he
was once again stonewalled being told
that any information regarding the
project was above his level of clearance
in a move that seemed decidedly spiteful
agent Kish signed off by saying that he
looked forward to seeing Dr Long at site
91 and not long after that he did agent
Kish along with a huge number of agents
and task force members from the multi-u
Department arrived on site bearing
state-of-the-art containment equipment
an exasperated Dr Long wasn't able to
glean any more information from this
experience the multi-u agents were
ruthlessly efficient transferring The
Lion's Share of the anomalies into
temporary containment and transporting
them off-site within a few hours by the
time they were done Dr long and his
staff were left with one of the most
desolate and empty containment sites on
the foundation's books here was Dr long
with Decades of service and climbing the
organizational ladder only to be left as
a glorified babysitter for a handful of
low priority anomalous items it all felt
like a cruel joke after several days of
nothing happening in the now incredibly
uneventful site-91 a board Doctor Long
reached out to a friend of his
researcher nurul shafiqe binte Ahmad
Ibrahim whom he called by the nickname
Shack to vent his frustrations she
commiserated sharing her sympathy for
his suddenly much less exciting working
conditions but saying that at least the
job should be a little less lethal now
Shaq didn't know it yet but on this
particular Point she was terribly wrong
Dr Long shared his theory that perhaps
some sites were being Consolidated so
the foundation could save money and that
this would lead to layoffs Shaq
essentially told him that he was
worrying too much the reality was that
Dr long had some very good reasons to be
worried his problem was that he hadn't
been worrying about the right things in
Foundation containment area 179
something awful was brewing as usual
God's posted around
scp-2317 an old door containing a portal
to another world waited while Foundation
staff and d-classes performed the
standard procedure 220 Calabasas ritual
within they were dealing with one of the
most dangerous anomalies in the entire
universe but even then after Decades of
service one can be numb to such things
suddenly without warning the door opened
in a terrified Foundation researcher
tumbled out panting heavily eyes bulging
in existential horror he screamed the
words that he long hoped would never be
spoken in his or even his children's
lifetime it happened the chains have
broken the Devourer is free the sirens
sounded and an alert spread across the
entire Foundation database
scp-2317 is compromised
scp-2317-k the Devourer of Worlds is
free if the creature escapes area 179 an
XK Class end of the world scenario is
basically assured so all efforts will be
taken to make sure that the creature
does not Escape at any cost and they
really did mean any cost the old wooden
door of scp-2317 splintered as an
immense scaly hand sprang forth and
caught a wave of Devastation throughout
the containment chamber guards were
dispatched in the hundreds with heavy
Weaponry to buy some time firing at the
Devourer a beast the size of a mountain
Rose from the ground staring at the
terrified humans below with its one
gigantic red eye it couldn't even feel
the bullets explosives or incendiary and
Laser Weaponry being used on it the
monster just Shrugged it off and
murdered nearly all of its attackers
with one swipe of its claw in a final
desperate act hoping to kill or at least
slow down the Beast staff at area 179
made the ultimate sacrifice and
detonated the entire on-site nuclear
Arsenal the explosion disintegrated the
entire facility in an instant and
Unleashed a radioactive shock wave that
carried Destruction for miles but it
wasn't enough
scp-2317-k walked out of the mushroom
cloud without a scratch on it ready to
show the human world what real
destruction meant at this point the
battle was already effectively lost but
the foundation refused to go down
without a fight they dispatched all
available mobile task forces including
mobile Task Force new 7 hammer down a
heavily armed Battalion strength task
force created combat the biggest and
most extensive threats imaginable and it
wasn't even just the foundation true
existential threats have a way of
uniting people as the GOC and even the
chaos Insurgency temporarily put aside
their differences to take the fight to
the Devourer but would any of it be
enough barrages of cruise missiles and
icbms did nothing to Halt the devourer's
assault as it rampaged destroying towns
and cities at first then regions then
whole Nations swarms of scrambled Jets
and helicopters were knocked out of the
sky with casual swipes the creature
bulldozed over Landscapes teeming with
tanks and heavy artillery Vehicles it
snapped aircraft carriers in half as it
waited from Ocean to Ocean
systematically destroying everything in
its path even satellite-mounted orbital
cannons and the heavy energy weapons of
MTF tau5 also known as samsara did
nothing to phase the devour it was
finally coming to fruition the dreaded
XK Class end of the world scenario and
none of the foundation's expertise
advanced technology or Limitless
resources could do anything to stop it
they aided in evacuation efforts getting
as many people as they could out of
Harm's Way as the Devourer rampaged and
destroyed but even that was doing little
more than borrowing time eventually the
Devourer would destroy all of them there
would be nothing left and all Dr James
long could do was watch helplessly from
an almost empty site-91 waiting for the
tide of Destruction to reach him of
course other Foundation employees most
prominently senior agent Sven Kish and
the multi-u department had other
concerns all they needed to do was
archive data for extraction extraction
to where you ask seeing as the world
seems to be at its end here while
Universe 7392 Epsilon blue Lima
otherwise known as our universe Circa
1993 the foundation Works across the
Multiverse and an XK class into the
world scenario in one Universe really
isn't necessarily a problem in others on
orders of the o5 council agent Kish and
his men are charged with extracting data
and valuable anomalies like SCP-173 from
doomed universes o5 knew that Dr Long's
Universe Universe 5643 gamma orange
Delta was due for an apocalyptic visit
from the Devourer of Worlds any day now
that's why the multi-u team went in to
extract everything worth Saving Dr long
and the millions of other level 4 and
Below employees of that universe's
Foundation were never told of their
Impending Doom after all that sort of
thing could probably lead to unnecessary
stress and what they don't know won't
hurt them until of course it does in
1993 these anomalous doomed Universe
scps were divided amongst our universe's
various applicable containment sites
SCP-173 as you already know ended up in
site 19 but sadly for the people working
there all the actual data files on this
entries file Were Lost in Translation so
as far as they knew 173 he was little
more than a big weird statue with
apparently dangerous properties upon
first placing it in its containment
chamber in site-19 Euclid Wing
Foundation Legend Dr bright unaware of
just what he had here A Sign Dr William
Moto to begin research on the entity he
recommended that the researcher bring
two d-classes for testing when Dr Moto
was faced with the anomalous entity's
blank file he gave a sign began to write
something in its description box moved
to site 19 1993 origin is as of yet
unknown wasn't that a delightful little
tale now we know how SCP-173 made its
way into site-19 and what our own
universe may have to look forward to in
2045 so remember if you ever see agent
Sven Kish planning a transfer of
anomalies out of your site maybe
consider using some of that PTO and
maybe consider Putting a down payment on
a nice cozy apocalypse bunker over in
Iceland no of other Tales you'd like to
see us cover let us know down in the
comments below please good sir I beseech
you as a man of science nay as a man of
reason you mustn't stifle my research at
this critical juncture you have no idea
how close I am to finding a cure for
this blasted pestilence I need only a
handful of Life subjects to complete my
research the black doctors emphatic
pleas fell on deaf ears as a stone-faced
researcher took notes on his latest
pontifications the doctor whom these
clods had reduced so rudely to a mere
number as cp049 banged his gloved fist
up against the wall and to think he once
thought of these men as intellectual
equals fellow Travelers on the road to
Scientific Enlightenment what a
positively sick joke before the doctor
got another chance to appeal for his
right to experiment the researcher left
him alone once
a truly sad State of Affairs nobody
appreciated a true scientist in this day
and age it was sure to be another day of
languishing alone in this cell wishing
he had the capacity to do more so he was
surprised as anyone when the alarm
started going off and the door of his
cell swung open automatically the plague
doctor stepped out of his cell and into
the Hall where many other humanoid
anomalies were roaming confused as to
why they'd been suddenly released what
was happening as it turned out what was
happening was one of the most brutal
chaos Insurgency raids the staff of site
19 had ever seen it had been planned
immaculately you see guards rotate
semi-regularly at site 19 due to the
high pressure nature of the job lots of
deaths and mental breakdowns as you
probably correctly predicted even the
administrative staff of the SCP
Foundation are only human well mostly
anyway so they're not immune to little
oversights here and there and it's in
those oversights that expertly train
chaos Insurgency infiltration agents
make their living no less than 15 of
them had been working undercover in
site-19 for just over two weeks and they
did a fine job of lowering the
metaphorical drawbridge for a heavily
armed Invasion Force the guards who
weren't plants were quickly murdered by
the infiltrators and even some of the
on-site task forces were quickly
overwhelmed and gunned down by the high
Precision rifles of the chaos
insurgency's finest while the front
liners were distracted by the sudden
assault the infiltrators found their way
to the site security control room and
massacred everyone inside opening every
single door in the site was as simple as
putting in a few stolen key codes and
flipping a few carefully remembered
switches consequently while Foundation
agents and Chaos Insurgency mercenaries
Clash Sabers high priority anomalies
like scp-049 simply wandered the
facility watching the Calamity unfold
within the foundation was set on all
sides shot at by heavily armed maniacs
and attacked from within by the numerous
roaming anomalous entities that were
eager to get their hands on Foundation
Personnel definitely not an ideal
situation to say the least the plague
doctor only had one thing on his mind
though hmm he's definitely went to my
research any good unless I can escape
and find my way to a suitable laboratory
oh now there is an idea but his
scientific fantasies were soon
interrupted by a chaos Insurgency
Soldier swinging the butt of his M4
carbine into his avian exoskull with a
supremely unpleasant crack the doctor
was Dazed by it momentarily the pain
coming at him like a Thunderclap but the
Insurgent never got the chance to take
another swing before the Insurgent could
do anything the plague doctor lunged out
with practice speed grasping him by the
throat immediately everything went black
and the insurgents limp corpse collapsed
to the ground serves the doctor
internally amused soldiers attacking
Medics is violating even the most basic
rules of gentlemanly warfare then
another flash of immense pain has a
different rifle but collided with the
back of his head the doctor fell to one
knee feeling dizzy but before he could
retaliate he felt the two sharp prongs
of a cattle prod pressing up against his
neck the Sudden Rush of electricity
surged through his neck sending his
muscles into a wave of involuntary
spasms the insurgents crowding around
him chimed in with their own agonizing
cattle prods relentlessly shocking him
until the flashes of white hot pain soon
became an impressive blanket of total
dark even on his most cantankerous days
the SCP Foundation had never treated him
like this when he eventually came to he
was still in darkness standing upright
with high-tech shackles holding every
limb in place it was beyond
uncomfortable for the poor plague doctor
but it succeeded in the task of keeping
him under control he couldn't move an
inch there were muffled voices beyond
the dark beyond the confines of this new
containment the modulated gas mask
voices of insurgents and something else
faintly accented oddly familiar but he
couldn't quite place it soon the voices
were replaced by another sound the
grinding of crowbars Levering Nails out
of cheap wood with a creaking tumble a
rectangle of bright light opened up in
front of him populated by a number of
silhouettes on either side were chaos
insurgents in familiar tactical Garb and
in between them stood a tall
well-groomed man with an expensive
looking purple smoking jacket and a
pencil mustache for a few fractions of a
second his face was a portrait of
excitement but as he took in the sight
of the plague doctor standing before him
all the joy drained from his snooty
continents what the hell am I looking at
here the man in the smoking jacket said
the doctor indignant adds such a
response from the man who'd presumed
ordered his assault rasped a man of
science could sir the man in the smoking
jacket ignored him and continued to
berate the chaos insurgents with an odd
level of confidence for someone
reprimanding trained cold-blooded
Killers I wanted scp-650 the startling
statue not this clownish Ren Fair
cosplayer what the hell did I pay you
Ruffians for I was told you chaos
insurgents were the very best at this
and for your Hefty price I expect
Excellence the rent continued much like
this leaving everyone in attendance the
insurgents the plague doctor feeling
thoroughly exhausted by him and unable
to do anything about it you see this
wasn't just any chaos Insurgency client
your average tin pot dictator or arms
dealer you know the time this was the
one and only Pascal legat one of the
most famous or rather Infamous anarch
collectors in the game he'd been a
founding Person of Interest for years
due to his dealings with the chaos
Insurgency and Marshall Carter and dark
limited all to the end of expanding his
anarch collection but his vast wealth
and connections had always shielded him
from Foundation probes for those
unfamiliar with the subculture and art
short for anomalous art is exactly what
it sounds like artistic projects with
anomalous properties to give it that
extra kick one of the most popular
groups of Interest dealing in an art is
the iconic are we cool yet which
incidentally had recently excommunicated
Pascal Legette for being an exceedingly
wealthy uptight Square who really didn't
represent the collective's rebellious
ethos and considering his response was
to pay the chaos Insurgency to raid
sight 19 for a few pieces for his own
private collection costing him millions
of dollars in both groups many lives it
was safe to say he wasn't taking it well
look we got to that other Statue and
that thing killed four of our best guys
so how about we just call it even said
one of the insurgents I'm sure you can
have fun with bird brain here too Pascal
tunned it and reluctantly dismissed the
higher guns having the plague doctor
here definitely wasn't ideal especially
considering he wanted to host the
ultimate an art exhibition to put are we
cool yet worthless
Magnifique to shame but he would make do
with what he had perhaps he could say
that 049 was a commentary on the
ever-present nature of disease in
Mankind's life and our forever archaic
approach to it yes yes that would do
nicely needless to say the plague doctor
was infuriated by all this the violence
against his person the kidnapping the
disrespect and most of all the
interruption to his precious research
especially considering how close he'd
gotten to finding a cure for the
pestilence but instead he was soon
spirited by a legion of heavily armed
goons from his wooden box to a glass one
in one of legette's many opulent
hallways there were other glass cases on
either side of him and more on the other
side of the hall all two reinforced for
the plague doctor to even smash through
it on his own damn it legette's own
private and art exhibition probably
wedged between his oversized dining room
and his jewel encrusted crapper
occasionally Pascal himself would jaunt
down the hallway to gaze upon his new
stolen anarch pieces and of course the
plague doctor would try his best to
reason with him I am a patient man this
is simply barbaric by what right do you
imprison me here is your intention to
deprive the world the entire human race
of my valuable medical breakthroughs
could you live with that on your
conscience good sir there was never any
meaningful response the plague doctors
soon learned that Pascal Legette didn't
like his art interactive it was simply
meant to languish away in a glass box
being watched being passively looked at
those chaos Insurgency louds hadn't even
bothered to bring his notebook or
medical bag so he was without the tools
to even perform his experiments as
loathed as he was to admit it this was
even worse than being mocked up by the
SCP Foundation but all this wasn't in
entirely unfamiliar there was something
in the glass box across from the plague
doctor that he vaguely recognized back
from site 19. he'd never seen it up
close but he'd heard researchers
speaking about it and even seen a few
pictures and such a strange construction
it was a peculiar haphazard sculpture
made from concrete rebar and spray paint
quite ugly in this humble doctor's
opinion but there was something oddly
entrancing about it and for reasons
beyond the doctor's recollection four of
legette's men stood around the glass box
in where it was being stored always
watching the man were frequently
switched in and out as though they were
watching in shifts always fixing their
Gaze on its peculiar malformed body
maybe it was all the electrical shocks
and knocks to the head but he just
couldn't remember why Pascal was having
the piece so carefully observed but he
knew on some Primal level that the
secret to this would perhaps be the key
to his own Escape if only he could
remember still time passed Pascal
drifted in and out sometimes with guests
the plague doctor had learned not to
speak these animals could not be
reasoned with as a scientist he would
instead carefully observe until his
observations bore fruit he noticed that
Pascal's guests all people who looked
equally as wealthy and pompous as Pascal
himself all seemed to look right over
him and instead focus on the ugly statue
across the hall still forever observed
by any four of Pascal's men some of them
looked actively nervous just being in
its presence curious the plague doctor
made a mental note of this just as he
did when Pascal gave his guests a
reassuring pat on the shoulder and told
them please calm yourself it's harmless
while my Personnel are keeping an eye on
it little by little the plague doctor's
memories of his Infamous neighbor had
begun to return he knew what he must do
to escape now all he needed to do was
wait for the perfect moment soon enough
Pascal's mention was filled with a bevy
of anarch snobs from hither and yarn a
private Soiree to show off his new
collection they wandered the halls in
three-piece Tuxedos and designer
ballroom dresses sipping champagne from
imported Crystal all such lovely refined
High Society people and if the good
doctor's plan went off as he intended
they would all be such lovely refined
High Society corpses the plague doctor
waited until mercifully he and the four
members of personnel watching the
sculpture were the only ones left in the
hallway he'd been so good so patient
that none of the men guarding the
sculpture at present had ever heard him
make a noise he was so invisible to them
that in all likelihood they probably
didn't even notice he could make a sound
and Matt worked for his purposes just
fine though in any case if he wanted
this to work he would need to time his
plan perfectly even a fraction of a
second out of place in the whole thing
would have dire consequences still the
doctor was still a Frenchman at heart
and as a Frenchman he knew he would
rather die nobly in the process of
Escape than remain captured by this
worthless buffoon he'd be sure to take
as many of these men down with him in
the process as he was able the plague
doctor exhaled deeply drawing a lung
full of air then bellowed as loud as he
possibly could the sudden unexpected
noise was so shocking that it jog the
four Watchers almost reflexively to turn
and look at him and in the split second
that they did the plague doctor closed
his eyes in the dark times seemed to
move slower perhaps due to the doctor's
Keen Focus cultivated over many a
century he listened carefully to the
sequence of sounds glass shattering four
choked gasps in sequence four brutal
crunches then nanoseconds later more
glass shattering the plague doctor's
eyes snapped open just in time just as
predicted the sculpture being entirely
unobserved had smashed through its glass
case murdering all four members of
personnel by snapping their necks and
then smashed through his own glass case
to do the same to him the plague doctor
had cut it so close in fact that he
opened his eyes to the face of the
sculpture staring into his own its
concrete limbs wrapped around his neck
very good timing indeed with a sigh of
relief the plague doctor slipped out of
the sculpture's concrete grasp and
backed down the hallway keeping his gaze
fixed stunned the sculpture the entire
time he had heard it decimate Pascal's
men he certainly didn't fancy undergoing
the same fate the second the plague
doctor backed around the corner
rendering the sculpture or as the SCP
Foundation called it SCP-173 out of
sight he could hear terrified screaming
coming from the other end of the hall he
was not a sadistic man but the plague
doctor would be lying if he told you he
didn't take just a little bit of
pleasure in hearing that sound somewhere
else in the vast Mansion of Pascal
Legette the sculpture was slaughtering
its way through servants and party
guests while the plague doctors searched
for some kind of exit anyone who dared
getting in his way was given a Swift and
merciless Touch of death sending their
body unceremoniously to the ground
anyone in his way was preventing him
from finding a cure for the pestilence
and thus endangering countless lives it
was of course regrettable to have to
kill anyone but some sacrifices must be
made for the greater good of mankind
well it's not necessarily always
regrettable per se on his way out while
the murderous Rampage of SCP-173 seemed
to distract anyone of note the plague
doctor just so happened to encounter a
fleeing Pascal legat hoping to find some
kind of Escape himself it seemed that
now fate was on his side once more to
have his Jailer right here in the palm
of his hand would be such a perfect
Parting Gift funnily enough Pascal was
far more talkative to him now he rattled
off a rapid fire series of threats
bribes and pleas claiming in the end
that he never meant any harm he was the
one who freed the play doctor from the
SCP Foundation they were on the same
side here all this was for the art no
offense was ever intended Pascal Legette
simply lived for art then die for it
good sir the plague doctor said and with
a single touch Pascal's eyes rolled up
into the back of his head and he fell to
the ground dead it was one of the few
non-scientific deaths that he felt truly
no guilt for after some time searching
the screams around the rest of the
Mansion eventually went silent that did
wonders for his focus it didn't take
long for the plague doctor to locate an
exit a fine mahogany door with elaborate
adornments befitting a man as gaudia's
Pascal and began strolling towards it
his chest swollen with pride and a sense
of accomplishment then he blinked and a
few feet in front of him stood the
sculpture it was there so suddenly that
the plague doctor fell backwards in
shock but he devoted everything to
keeping an eye on that monstrosity with
everyone else in the Mansion presumably
dead at this point it had now come back
for him it stood there staring silently
ready to exact the terrible price for
freeing it as soon as the doctor dared
to Blink the plague doctor began
crawling backwards down the hall just
wanting to put some distance between
himself and the sculpture as the seconds
passed he could feel his eyes drying out
until the inevitable blink the sculpture
was standing right in front of him now
gazing down almost mocking it had closed
the distance so quickly if the plague
doctor blinked again he was sure that
his eyes would never open again all it
had to do was wait as the seconds passed
and the doctor began to feel his eyes
drying up again that subtle sting
quickly grew into a nagging pain that
could not be denied sooner or later he
was going to have to bang the front door
flew open and in an instant the hallway
was filled with heavily armed troops all
wearing the familiar black and gray of
the s
Foundation the plague doctor had never
been so relieved to see the organization
that had kept him locked up for so many
decades for once they'd saved him from
something even worse of course the
sculpture didn't say anything but the
disappointment of losing that one more
victim seemed to radiate off of it like
a lingering bad smell the plague doctor
willingly gave himself up and heavy
machinery was brought in to pick up
SCP-173 with the help of the iPods to
make sure it didn't try any funny
business in transit Pascal had gotten
away with his Shady dealings for years
but the Brazen attack he funded against
site-19 was now enough for the
foundation to track him down when his
corpse was found in the halls of his own
home with no obvious cause of death we
can happily tell you that nobody was
disappointed by the evening the plague
doctor was happy to be back in his cell
his research could continue here and in
time he knew that the Personnel of the
SCP Foundation would listen to reason
and comply with his demands after all
science Marches On regardless of who
chooses to march with it but he would
forever feel a little nervous in site 19
after that knowing the concrete monster
he was sharing the building with he
hoped that if ever there was another
Containment Breach involving that thing
that it didn't feel like paying him a
visit for old time's sake Dr Dan
anxiously paced in his cell it was the
only way he'd been able to occupy
himself for the past six months save for
pouring through files and when he was
lucky being able to oversee another
failed termination attempt he only
stopped pacing when for a brief and
horrible moment he realized that monster
was probably doing the exact same thing
in its big metal cube at this very
moment that horrible creature that he'd
thrown away his life for a feudal shot
at killing perhaps the whole thing had
been a Fool's errand after all he was
formerly a researcher under the employee
of the SCP Foundation secure contain
protect they had truly sadistic beasts
like scp-106 the nightmarish old man and
scp-352 Baba Yaga in containment cells
and there was no plans to terminate
either of them they weren't the global
occult Coalition for 343's sake why did
Dr Dan even want to terminate
scp-096 in the first place he tried to
explain it to them again and again but
his pleas had fallen on deaf ears in his
mind the impetus for destroying the shy
guy was terrifyingly clear it was a
monster that killed anyone or anything
that looked at its face even a
photograph of it even a tiny collection
of pixels when its rage state was
induced it seemed that nothing would
stop it it would have an intuitive
psychic link to its victim charge at
them at Breakneck speed and only find it
Zen again once all of them were dead and
if a picture of scp-096 6 was leaked
onto the internet it would cause a chain
reaction that triggered an XK class and
the world scenario there were plenty of
creatures and entities that the
foundation knew about that could
theoretically bring about the apocalypse
but to him 096 was the most realistic he
preyed upon the inherent curiosity and
thirst for knowledge seeded in every
human heart the same drive to Simply
know that led to the creation of the SCP
Foundation would be Humanity's Doom in
the face of an scp-096 outbreak and if
such a thing happened the foundation
would need to break the Masquerade of
secrecy to have any hope of saving
Humanity in his many feverish nightmares
Dr Dan had seen it all so clearly the
first photographs of scp-096's face
would be leaked online perhaps a few
hundred people across the globe would
look in disparate enough locations that
it would be almost impossible for the
foundation to detect and save all of
them as SC
p096 went on its bloody Rampage of
course as the image proliferated as
images on the internet often do the
purview of 096's violence would only
grow people across the nation would
start to take notice and soon after that
across the world mysterious creature
causing Mass casualties would be the
headline on every news desk because why
would anybody want to talk about
anything else perhaps some foolish
reporters would take video footage of
the creature everyone has a phone these
days with high definition cameras
pictures would be taken and posted more
and more of it would flood the internet
too many simultaneous moles for even the
SCP Foundation to whack the news would
spread panic and hysteria would spread
people wouldn't even know what's
triggering all this horror if the
foundation didn't go public and tell
them that it was the pictures that was
killing everyone and by then wouldn't it
already be too late the antidote to fear
is knowledge it's why when anything goes
wrong where refreshing timelines and
feeds and news websites for any kind of
information and if you were told an
Unstoppable monster was killing scores
of people and might be coming to a
neighborhood near you sometime soon
wouldn't you want a good look at it
wouldn't you want to know your enemy
having no idea that the mere Act of
knowing was what sealed your horrible
Fate by Dr Dan's Bleak estimations if
only several million people died as a
result of this kind of scenario it could
be considered a positive outcome he'd
seen it all but no matter how many times
he tried to articulate this to his
superiors he wasn't listened to they
didn't take him or the threat that
scp-096 posed seriously every time he
warned of the apocalyptic potential of
scp-096 he was simply told to get back
to working on those goggles it was why
he needed to give those naysayers a
demonstration it was why a certain
photograph needed to show up in the home
of a certain Mountaineer it's why all
those people had to die there was no
other way the deaths of the civilians
and the researchers and the mobile task
force members were of course regrettable
but it was the only way to prevent the
deaths of so many more they gave him
what he wanted permission to put this
gangly time bomb in the ground even if
the beast's death was inextricably tied
to his own execution at the hands of the
very employers who authorized him the
world was full of funny little ironies
like that another one is that even
though Dr Dan now had the authorization
and funding to terminate
scp-096 he was discovering that he
lacked another important factor the
capability they tried incinerating it
exposing it to massive amounts of
radiation exposing it to an insane
degree of genetic trauma the equivalent
of being hit by an out of control bullet
train they tested every kind of
experimental off the books Weaponry that
they had access to through various
research projects proton blasts lasers
high intensity energy beams nothing even
when they fried off every scrap of flesh
on the monster's body its unbreakable
skeletons still remained and in what
seemed like no time at all it'd be back
in Action its very existence seemed to
mock him the guard opened his cell door
staring disdainfully at the disgraced
researcher that same guard had slammed
his head against a wall a month earlier
one of his friends had apparently been
killed in the legendary 096 Containment
Breach that set this whole sword thing
in motion up an atom scumbag he sat in
the gruff's early voice training a
handgun on the doctor he knew wouldn't
fight back they need you in test chamber
6. Dr Dan allowed himself off a small
grin imperceptible to the guard who
clearly hated his guts they'd approved
his 096 vs 682 cross test marvelous how
marvelous to all the others it would
seem like just one more entry in a long
line of 682 cross tests he thought it
Darkly funny in his eyes the foundation
had no hope of ever killing
scp-682 its defining quality was being
impossible to kill and it didn't present
nearly the threat to the entire world
that 096 posed their futile attempts to
murder the lizard were little more than
a money sink to justify the site's
exorbitant funding but perhaps he could
turn this to his benefit maybe scp-682
would hold the secret to actually
killing off his Nemesis within 30 hours
Dr Dan had his disappointing answer both
anomalies had undeniably done a real
number on each other and Dr Dan did take
a kind of sick Amusement in the mental
trauma that scp-682 had induced in 096
But ultimately it was all for nothing
682 had skin 096 alive and melted off
its flesh with acid but once again that
indestructible skeleton stood firm this
had been the 27th termination attempt
since the incident the 27th failed
termination attempt Dr Dan mentally
corrected himself 096's skeleton kept
defeating them even their most Ardent
attempts to penetrate the bones and
destroy the creature within had failed
during a previous attempt they tried to
access the brain by putting a diamond
hard drill into its eye sockets of
course it was the drill that actually
broke much to Dr Dan's seemingly
tireless frustration needless to say in
the debriefing interview with Dr Carver
a researcher who once would have
considered him a colleague he wasn't in
High Spirits if he managed to kill this
thing then he would always be the hero
who made a terrible sacrifice in order
to save many more lives if he didn't
kill 096 he was little more than the
monster who murdered all those innocent
people for nothing though you'd never
hear him say it out loud if it wasn't
for that damnable indestructible
skeleton this monster would be long dead
already if only there was some way to
break the creature's bones that's when
it hit him
SCP-173 the sculpture a site 19 icon
often overlooked because of its more
silent but deadly style but undeniably
one of the most frightening and
dangerous anomalies out there it had
racked up a truly shocking body count
since it was first interred at site 19
in 1993 one broken neck at a time and
it's one of the few creatures out there
that even the hard to destroy reptile
himself is utterly terrified of perhaps
a monster that practically has a PHD in
breaking bones would be the ideal
candidate to vandalize the Shy Guy's
vertebrae once his proposal was greenlit
for initial testing Dr Dan arranged for
the shy guy with a bag over his head of
course to be brought into a testing
chamber with the ever stoic
SCP-173 when all the researchers and
guards were safely outside all it took
was a single blink to make all of Dr
Dan's darkest dreams come true in the
nanoseconds his eyes were closed he
heard the most beautiful sounds in the
world a loud fleshy Crunch and a pained
howl from 096 he opened his eyes to an
equally wondrous sight zero nine six
doubled over at an unnatural angle its
spine snapped between the fourth and
fifth vertebrae spinal fluid leaking
down the creature's flank that freaky
little sculpture had done it it had
actually damaged the Integrity of the
Shy Guy's skeleton it was at that moment
that Dr Dan knew he could kill this
thing admittedly there was a Containment
Breach shortly after that when the bag
slipped off of 096's head and it charged
through the nearby steel wall killing
multiple people before being subdued and
recontained but when it comes to
projects involving Dr Dan a mere handful
of innocent people being killed sits
comfortably within the acceptable margin
of error a day later Dr Dan was standing
before a crowded boardroom with agents
researchers and even a few members of
the o5 council in attendance he
explained his findings to them and the
fact that even more importantly they may
have a way to bring The Wretched
existence of 096 to an absolute halt his
plans were approved not long after he
was putting them into motion Dr Dan was
surrounded by researchers and heavily
armed guards as 173 was escorted into
the test chamber with a forklift 096 was
there still bagged off to the side was a
giant tub of hydrofluoric acid connected
to a hose and injector attachment if
this didn't work nothing would everyone
stood back in a safe Zone as 173 was
released to do its thing crunch just
like the previous time 096's spine had
been successfully snapped spinal fluid
dribbled down its skin everyone had
rushed into the chamber one grouped kept
173 isolated with their stairs the other
headed by Dr Dan prepared the acid
injector and shoved it into the breach
in 096's spine as the acid was pumped by
the gallon into 096's Bones the creature
let out the most horrifying whale it
kicked and bucked as more acid was
pumped in melting those indestructible
Bones from within the creature even
began to vomit acid as it panicked
melting the bag off of its own head some
panicked and averted their gaze Dr Dan
didn't he stared directly at the
creature's face for the first time as it
melted in front of him with nothing
short of pure Elation heading one had he
actually won the creature let out a
gurgling shriek and the guards opened
fire their bullets splattered into the
monster's melting Flesh and Bones as it
hollered and treat they didn't let up
firing up and down its body spraying it
with white hot lead it began to melt and
bubble away expanding into a great
gruesome puddle on the floor beneath
them Dr Dan laughed like a madman even
as the guards grabbed him and dragged
him away from the foul-smelling greasy
mess bubbling with chemical life he just
kept laughing even though he knew the
death of 096 meant an equally Swift
death of his own it didn't matter it had
all been for something the world was
saved it was over he'd find
one room dark people gone can move I
happy trapped for years kept by men for
research left alone in room left to
scratch at walls left to rot and die
unless needed specimen for research
trapped by self never seen by others
never spoken listen but never speak see
but never seen made of rock when others
come free when they not look prisoner
when they look back I hate they have
freedom they move freely talk freely
look freely live freely I do not I
trapped silenced Rock subject prisoner I
do thing about it their necks fragile
their next week I stock them
they always come new ones come for
cleaning they look away I sneak up I
take hold they Panic they look and thy
prisoner they blink and I free I twist
they die neck makes sound not words or
scream or gurgle neck go crunch crunch
is beautiful sound crunch means and has
come crunch means man can torment no
more crunch means others Panic others
become easy crunch begins and crunch
ends I live for crunch life has no
meaning do nothing but walk and scrape
and hate they watch they send men
cleaning and life has meaning cleaning
means crunch crunch means purpose crunch
means life crunch means Choice crunch
means freedom crunch means everything
these are the dark and fragmented
thoughts that go through the mind of
SCP-173 also known as the sculpture as
it forever languishes in its dark filth
encrusted cell there are few anomalies
more strange and frightening than this
Twisted stack of concrete rebar and
Krylon brand spray paint it's the only
physical anomaly that can terrify both
as cp096 and scp-682 why what is it
about this monster that's so frightening
even in the context of an organization
that locks up frightening monsters every
single day perhaps it's the Simplicity
of it all there's no sympathizing no
empathizing no reasoning with it
scp-682 the hard destroy reptile
despises all life but you'd probably be
grumpy too if the SCP Foundation tried
to kill you every day
scp-096 the shy guy is an almost tragic
figure who kills out of a sadness and
rage that's altogether alien and also
far too familiar
scp-049 the plague doctor kills with
kindness his terrible crimes tempered by
his desire to help and do good
scp-106 the old man is a sadist but his
brand of evil is all too common in human
beings nothing is quite like
SCP-173 it's mine to the extent that we
can possibly understand it is almost
childlike in its violent Simplicity it
won't spare you because it doesn't even
have the capacity to recognize your
Humanity it'll kill you because your
eyes are its prison and it likes the
sound your neck makes when it snaps
nothing more nothing less it raises an
interesting question
for a creature with a mind so
terrifyingly simple yet utterly
impenetrable how would it react to some
fundamental change to a shift in
circumstances that would forever alter
the way it interfaces with the world
around it it was a question that many in
SCP Foundation researcher had racked
their brilliant over-educated brains
over as it turned out the day of that
great and terrible change was coming but
very few members of the SCP Foundation
staff would survive to see it through
that morning started for SCP-173 the way
that so many others had in the torturous
series of patterns and repetitions that
had become its life three of those
stupid ugly men in the orange overalls
were standing in its cell again freezing
it in place with their gazes and taking
turns to clean can you even imagine how
it feels to want with all your might to
move but being paralyzed locked in place
doomed to Simply watch as you are
watched
humiliation would never end that's when
all the alarms went off and the flashing
lights and the people yelling and
screaming outside it's so sudden and
shocking that the d-classes look around
the room searching in vain for answers
there's one beautiful second where the
stars align and SCP-173 is out of their
Collective field of vision as their eyes
pan and scan and that second is enough
crunch crunch crunch all three fall to
the ground next Twisted at unnatural
angles and SCP-173 is alone in the room
once more it waits a few moments for the
others to come storming in paralyzing it
with their stupid looks again but it
never happens just alarms and distant
screens 173 wonders in its own simple
detached fashion what's going on outside
right now are more of those nasty men
the prison wardens getting crunch out
there if so as cp-173 was eager to join
in on all the fun the murderous
sculpture smashed its door from its
hinges outside chaos scene to rain
people were running in every direction
other anomalies had seemingly breached
containment armed mobile task force
operatives were running to and fro
receiving panicked chatter from the
radios fix to their tactical vests it
was a site that SCP-173 had seen so many
times before but something was different
this time something was in the air some
strange and undefinable thing it had
never seen those nasty men look so
afraid yes good everything was going to
be different now
SCP-173 took its chances waiting for
moments where it was unseen by the
hordes of terrified guards and
researchers scrambling through site 19
like headless chickens crunch crunch
crunch it left a trail of dead bodies
with severed spinal columns and
vandalized vertebrae in its wake it it
was so strange by now they normally
would have dispatched a dedicated team
to come and spoil all the fun or sent
those absurd little iPods but today it
seemed like nobody was even looking at
SCP-173 it was almost like a dream a
wonderful wonderful dream uninterrupted
Play Time uninterrupted crunch again and
again and again stacking those bodies up
like it was Judgment Day it was the most
fun that SCP-173 had experienced in
years as it continued its new Rampage
through psych 19. there were a few
different strange and interesting things
that it couldn't help but notice for
starters the fact that all of the
windows even the skylights had suddenly
been covered the majority had proper
shutters but others had opaque Fabric or
even cardboard sheets nailed over them
that didn't seem to be a very effective
method of keeping their prisoners inside
so perhaps they were trying to keep
something out but the Limited mind of
SCP-173 wasn't on what could be lurking
outside site 19 but rather killing as
many people as it possibly could before
this lovely dream needed to come to an
end as all lovely dreams sadly do crunch
crunch crunch researchers guards
administrators all of them died just the
same it was glorious there were so many
people to Crunch here and yet still so
few of them seem to be doing anything to
resist before when it had escaped and
decided to have its fun they'd mobilize
so quickly to throw cold water on the
festivities what a change now what was
taking up all of their attention this
flicker of curiosity was soon replaced
by an even more exciting possibility if
it was somehow unnoticed inside perhaps
it could take another opportunity to
venture outside again and have some real
fun it had been so long since it felt
the sun on its concrete shell so long
since the fresh air had rushed against
its chipping paint there would be so
much crunch out there and when night
fell nothing would stop it it knew the
way out nobody would accuse SCP-173 of
being a genius of course but it watched
and listened and remembered everything I
remember the day it was carried into the
building on a forklift and could retrace
every step back to the front door it was
clear the fine folks of the SCP
Foundation were otherwise occupied so
173 would have to show itself out
twisting a few more necks on the way
just for fun of course by the time it
swung open the doors of an access Bay it
had already racked up an impressive body
count for this breach who knows how
deadly its total would be before it was
recaptured and put back into containment
it might even score a personal best but
the second it saw what was going on
outside it realized the gravity of the
situation its strange Primal hunch that
the world would somehow be fundamentally
different now seem to be true because
even the site 19 parking lot had
descended into absolute chaos cars had
crashed trash cans were on fire and
strangest of all there were these Blobby
gelatinous creatures slithering around
painted in the various Hues and tones of
human flesh but 173 had escaped the
facility proper for the first time in
years and it certainly wasn't going to
waste its Newfound freedom on hanging
around a parking lot when none of the
strange flesh blobs were looking at it
it took off towards the nearest
population Center to have a little
informal celebration there would still
be plenty of people to Crunch out there
and this homicidal sculpture couldn't be
more excited to get started it was a
long road from site 19 to the nearest
city after all the largest SCP
Foundation containment site on Earth
wasn't going to park itself in close
proximity to tens of millions of prying
eyes not to mention potential victims if
or rather when something dangerous got
out but seeing as it still seemed nobody
was coming to recapture SCP-173 it
really didn't mind taking the scenic
route it was a good thing that the
sculpture wasn't driving though because
the closer it got to the city the more
the roads seemed to be choked with
gridlock traffic interesting though none
of the cars had anyone inside many were
just stalled there with the radios
playing every single one played the
exact same message in perfect
synchronicity this is a public service
[Music]
and frequencies
avoid sunlight at all costs cover your
bodies thoroughly and follow the
instructions on the screen to reach the
newest operational SCP Foundation
SCP-173 lost interest in the radio
Babble quickly it heard enough of these
kinds of sanctimonious sounds back in
containment out here it was hoping to
hear another sound entirely and it only
needed to go a little further to get
there as the sculpture Drew even closer
to the nearest city it noticed more of
those strange gelatinous flesh creatures
slithering across the road each of them
seemed to be at a different stage of
melting and strangely none of them
really seemed to mind they were sluicing
across the ground minding their own
business none of these strange melted
creatures perhaps human beings once seem
to pay any mind to SCP-173 it was almost
surreal to have this much freedom of
movement but SCP-173 wasn't about to
look a gift horse in the mouth things
were worse when it reached the city it
was chaos the aftermath of what seemed
like total social collapse Vehicles had
crashed into each other in the streets
or barreled into the front of nearby
buildings glass smashed and shattered
all over the ground all broken TVs and
radios playing the same message of
caution and false hope from the SCP
Foundation and everywhere more of the
these unpleasant crawling fleshy things
slithering around the remnants of the
recent Carnage it was clear to even
SCP-173 that the world had changed in
some fundamental way but the hows and
whys remain just as unclear as they did
back in site 19. that's humans for you
they always know how to mess something
up speaking of it was at that moment
that SCP-173 noticed a human in the
distance standing in the shade of a
ruined storefront their arms were filled
with valuables perhaps from a less than
legal shopping spree in whatever
building that used to be a wonderful
opportunity for crunch there were maybe
a hundred or so feet between the human
and 173 and it knew the second the human
looked away it would be easy to close
the distance and deliver one more sad
soul into the void with a playful little
twist the human stepped out from the
darkness of the broken storefront and
into the light turning their ignorant
gaze away from the singularly Sinister
statue yes yes perfect in a Flash 173
closed half the distance the human was
moving so slowly it would be so easy to
catch up one more Flash and it was
standing right behind the human its
concrete arms wrapped around the hapless
human's head squeeze and of course twist
but no crunch
SCP-173 was startled nothing broke there
was only this quiet almost imperceptible
squishing noise as the head of the human
twisted around 180 degrees to stare into
whatever past for scp-173's face it saw
that even in what should have been death
the human was just running placidly but
that's the most frightening part 173
realized that this human wasn't dead it
was just changing it saw the facial
features starting to lose definition
melting and dripping away like candle
wax in the hot sun moments later what
was once human was now something
entirely different it melted away into
another one of those slippery slithering
pseudo mollusks and crawled away into
the street somehow completely
indifferent to scp-173's attempt on its
life there was no fear no death no
crunch for the first time in its long
and terrible existence the sculpture
couldn't help but feel a little afraid
once again it didn't fully understand
what was going on here but whatever had
changed in this world had taken away
crunch it had taken away the thing that
made the pathetic sham that some might
call life worth living for SCP-173 but
it wasn't going to give up that easily
no crunch had to still be out there
somewhere this was what began as
cp-173's Odyssey into this horrible New
World the world in the aftermath of what
the SCP Foundation began to call
scp-001 when day breaks it was the most
dangerous and horrifying anomaly that
the foundation had ever interfaced a
successful XK Class end of the world
scenario for all intents and purposes it
had been so sudden and total any
exposure to the sun would cause a victim
to begin to melt taking on an
irreversible gelatinous State billions
were gone changed in the first hours of
this terrible New World it led to the
administrator of the SCP Foundation
releasing an internal memo that would
haunt the dreams of all those still
capable of dreaming for those of you
with families or God forbid children I'm
deeply deeply sorry you must push on do
not let their deaths be in vain we do
still have time humanity may still have
a future come to site 19. we need all
the hands we can get learn to embrace
the darkness friends fear the light and
this phenomenon didn't just affect
humans it affected animals and even
anomalies
scp-001 sun exposure seemed to nullify
any previous anomalous
leading to even some of the hardiest
anomalies melting like an ice cream cone
left out in the heat there was however
one exception to the rule inorganic
anomalies were exempt from the change
inorganic anomalies like say a certain
sculpture
SCP-173 continued searching for months
on end only seeming to come up against
more maddening dead ends it traveled
from City to city with frightening speed
trying its best to track down anyone
with enough spinal Integrity to produce
the crunch that made all the rest of
this terrible boredom worthwhile but no
luck every single city was more of these
flush monsters with bones too malleable
to snap if they even still had bones at
all there was another concerning
development in all this for SCP-173 the
flesh monsters were no longer just an
annoying waste of time or a symbol of
disappointment but an active nuisance to
the sculpture's goals they'd started
coagulating into these giant mountains
of living flesh that started actively
seeking out the last of the normal
humans from their dark crevices and
hiding places turning them into more of
those necklace jelly freaks did nobody
ever teach you animals to share
SCP-173 thought angrily the seeming loss
of crunch across this new world drove
SCP-173 into a deep depression it had
freedom but no joy it was adrift in a
meaningless world that seemed to exist
as some Cosmic punishment for crimes it
never committed in its own mind at least
it wasn't fair none of this was fair
would the sculpture just gather dust in
an empty Wasteland full of all this ugly
pointless slime and this was what it
left site 19 for and it was at that
moment that SCP-173 had a wonderful
awful idea back at site 19 things
weren't exactly going swell they lost
many of their Most Valuable Personnel
during the initial Panic of scp-001
they'd been stretched to resource
capacity by the sudden influx of
refugees from this broken new world and
of course there had been the attacks all
those terrible flesh mountains were
Relentless bombarding the site night
after night trying to drag people out
and expose them to the light it's why
mobile task force operatives were
stationed along the perimeter with heavy
Weaponry even though short-staffed as
they were these operatives were few and
far between one of them Commander Lewis
sat and stared into the distance keeping
an eye out for more of the flesh
mountains through the sights of his
rifle that's when he noticed a familiar
shape almost like a giant peanut since
you must be seeing things Lewis rubbed
his eyes and in that moment the thing he
thought he'd seen was behind him it
snapped his neck with a familiar
satisfying crunch just as quickly just
for a moment it seemed that all was
right with the world again if SCP-173
could smile it would smile and think
it's good to be back
SCP-173 it's a your statue with a bad
attitude and a penchant for
strangulation and snapping necks though
only if nobody has maintained unbroken
eye contact with it some know it as the
sculpture some know it as the peanut
some know it as probably the most
important anomaly of all considering
it's the one that got this whole crazy
Affair started but today we're here to
ask an important question do any of us
really know it at all after all its
original file is hardly comprehensive
you might even venture to say it's one
of the most enigmatic scps out there
despite its popularity but today we're
taking a dive beneath the concrete rebar
and Krylon brand spray paint to give you
the real inside scoop on
SCP-173 we've broken into the SCP
Foundation archive and found 10
different important files on this
Infamous vertebrae Vandal and we're
going to explore each and every one of
them with you today as you can expect
from the weird and wild SCP Foundation
they cover possible past presence and
Futures and some of them will naturally
contradict but that just gives you more
of an opportunity to immerse yourself
and compare them we often like to
believe that the real truth is somewhere
in between so make sure you pay
attention to every detail throughout so
let's get the show on the road and
explore our 10 documents of interest for
SCP-173 in hopes of finally getting the
complete story and of course don't blink
document one crunch where better to
start than the mind of the Sinister
sculpture itself crunch gives us an
insight into the private thoughts of
this otherwise pretty uncommunicative
Monster and reveals a great deal about
its relationship with its favorite
activity snapping the necks of anyone
who dares to look away from it in crunch
SCP-173 speaks in very basic broken
rorschach-esque English saying things
like
[Music]
left to
rot and die unless needed specimen for
research prompt by self never seen by
others never spoken listen but never
speak
but never seen made of rock when others
come free when they not look prisoner
when they look back
I hate
SCP-173 hates and resents its captors
for keeping it confined in its own mind
crunch how it refers to the snapping of
its victim's neck is the only thing that
gives its life a sense of meaning it
will continue to Crunch for as long as
it's contained because thanks to the SCP
Foundation crunch is all it has left
these days document 2 how 173 got to
site 19. this semi-origin story is one
that the fans of this channel will be
familiar with while it doesn't give us
any insight into why this nasty pile of
concrete actually exists it does inform
us why it's currently our problem
SCP-173 isn't actually an anomaly native
to our universe however its native
Dimension was destroyed by the Beast
trapped in SCP 2317 the Devourer of
Worlds as is standard procedure for a
universe about to experience an XK Class
end of the world scenario the
foundation's department of extra
dimensional Affairs swooped in and
collected all the valuable anomalies
before the world went down the tube one
of these was of course
SCP-173 which was vacated to site-19 in
our dimension in 1993. do you think we
would have been better off if we just
left him for the Devourer of Worlds to
take care of let us know what you think
about that down in the comments document
3 the black moon sometimes You Can Be
Your Own Worst Enemy if the file on
scp-001 the black moon is to be believed
the SCP Foundation may actually be
behind the creation of this ornery
object though in the foundation's
defense it was in service of potentially
fighting off a far more deadly foe the
ominous extra dimensional being known
only as the Black Moon one attempt to
stop the black moon from destroying the
univ members was known as the key
project which involved creating a number
of items linked to the black moon via
conceptual engineering that would
hopefully nullify its effects the
objects needed the following qualities
an inability to act while under
observation a hostility towards human
life and the capacity to end conscious
life if given the opportunity those
three descriptions fit SCP-173 to a T
and it was considered the Project's
greatest success however it sadly wasn't
enough to actually stop the horrific
Rampage of the black moon the researcher
managing the case Dr Moto was so ashamed
by the failure that he willingly entered
scp-173's containment chamber and got
his neck snapped in the process document
4 conclusions regarding
d-1732263 incident this document Finds
Its origins in the video analysis of a
foundation researcher with an incredibly
powerful name Dr Delano Smasher Dr
Smasher had closely observed video
footage of scp-1 173 killing several
members of d-class personnel and began
formulating a new theory about how 173
actually killed its victims doctor
Smasher theorized after all that
something with arms as short as SCP-173
and no opposable digits would have
trouble effectively strangling or
snapping human necks according to Dr
smasher's observations
SCP-173 doesn't actually make any
physical contact with its victims
instead the victims feel oddly compelled
to look at the Creature if ever nothing
is looking at it their eyes will snap
open and their heads will twist at any
angle they need to in order to look at
the creature in the eyes it's the sheer
force of this Sudden Change that often
leads to snapping necks and bruised
faces for the victims not the sculpture
itself physically causing the damage if
Dr Smasher is to be believed the
sculpture is deadly purely because it
simply demands to be looked at by
somebody at all times document 5
anniversary this brings us nicely to our
next document anniversary positing a
different theory for the mysterious
creation of SCP-173 this comes from the
perspective of said possible Creator an
anomalous entity that we'll call the
artist much like the unfortunate Dr Moto
the artist an intelligent being that can
seemingly become invisible and
intangible at will considered SCP-173 to
be its finest creation it viewed SCP-173
as a perfect representation of humanity
it does nothing but bleed and defecate
and if anyone refuses to pay attention
to it it kills them it was a perfect
symbol of the artist's contempt for
Humanity it even easily snuck into site
19 to visit SCP-173 on the anniversary
of its creation and found the
foundation's lack of appreciation for
this fine creation as an act of Revenge
for keeping his creation locked up and
out of sight for so long he gave the
sculpture permission just once to kill
someone one who looked away even if
others were still looking at it for
SCP-173 this would be considered a
wonderful little treat document 6 her
Masterpiece this next document known as
her Masterpiece suggests that SCP-173
was created by a very different kind of
artist while this potential creator of
SCP-173 was somehow able to produce an
anomaly she was not anomalous herself
just motivated by rage and revenge she'd
been pregnant in the past but lost the
baby due to the actions of a man whom
she considered her greatest enemy she
vowed to make art from his demise the
woman murdered her enemy with a baseball
bat before using concrete and rebar to
build SCP-173 around him almost as a way
to mock her Fallen foe however like
something out of a horror movie this act
of murderous creation somehow imbued
SCP-173 with life when this spiteful
artist had eventually finished the
creation and started to walk away it
claimed her as its first victim the last
thing she remembered hearing was the
sound of concrete scraping against the
ground and then a nasty crunch before
everything went dark document 7
regarding the statue from one tragedy to
another the document regarding the
statue shows the Journey of researcher
Marcus silburn from idealistic young
employee to full-on mental breakdown
after trying and failing to gain control
of SCP-173 he entered the SCP-173
project with bright eyes and big ideas
about how to contain the sculpture
suggesting that the human element be
removed entirely in order to reduce risk
to Foundation Personnel he proposed
ideas like introducing a sprinkler and
drainage system to the chamber and using
a sentient Ai and remote viewing
technology to keep SCP-173 immobilized
however he was then enlightened to some
frustrating and frightening facts about
SCP-173 in the absence of actual present
human obser reservation the same buildup
of feces and blood that the creature
somehow excretes builds up in any
technology used to control or contain it
it destroys the circuit boards of AIS
takes flying camera drones out of the
sky and even degrades the locks on its
chamber doors leading to the brutal
death of a janitor in the hall
researcher silbern Advanced far enough
through the ranks of the foundation to
be in direct communication with Dr Jack
Bright the director of site 19 after his
final attempt at containing the creature
without direct human observation
resulted in a Containment Breach and the
death of 12 people zilburn was moved off
the SCP-173 case after breaking down and
begging for permission to terminate the
anomaly permission was denied Dr bright
closed the document with a note to a
member of the o5 council reading it can
be surmised that our conclusion was
correct the object for whatever reason
desires or requires human attention and
will not be denied it document 8 a
chance at Freedom we once again return
turn to the direct perspective of
SCP-173 but this differs vastly from the
perspective of scp-173's inner monologue
presented in crunch according to the
document entitled a chance at Freedom
SCP-173 was actually an incredibly
intelligent agent of Espionage Sent From
Another Dimension along with its unknown
Cadet though the cadet is heavily
implied to be
scp-096 this piece details a Containment
Breach From scp-173's perspective as it
is shown looking down on humanity and
its primitive technology it laments the
fact that it lost its weapon during the
interdimensional transfer and it sees
that if it still had its weapon this all
would have played out very differently
despite conceding the fact that it
underestimated the humans which was the
main reason it ended up in containment
it spends the majority of the document
touting its own superiority until one of
the scp-131 the ibots turned up and
froze it in place the degree to which
SCP 173 hates the ibots cannot be
overstated document 9 experiences with
scp-682 of course no full story video on
SCP-173 would be complete without a
discussion of the scp-682 cross-tests a
number of researchers though
particularly the very persistent Dr
Carlson decided to use SCP-173 in
various manners in hopes of finally
doing in that damn lizard in their first
engagement 682 seemed rightfully
frightened of 173 and when a sniper shot
its eyes out 173 immediately snapped its
neck of course it grew back a series of
sniper proof eyes not long after someone
next suggested SCP-173 being sent in
with a picture of 096 taped to its chest
though this was rejected as being
ridiculous and Incredibly dangerous idea
to everyone thank you Dr Bryant the
researchers then went after scp-682 with
high Precision Blades cutting it to
Pieces Each of which became autonomously
dangerous enemies
SCP-173 then began to murder each of
those Blobs of the mutated tissue until
it stopped when a d-class was sent in to
stare at it while the rest of 682
regenerated
SCP-173 was transported back to its cell
but there was a brief power outage
during Transit leading 173 to kill a
number of the staff transporting it this
test was still considered a step in the
right direction after 682 was once again
shrunk by a different anomaly SCP-173
was released into its chamber at first
it appeared that 173 had actually killed
682 but a week later it returned having
reconstituted itself from matter that
had been splattered on 173 after it had
been brutalized making this test once
again a failure Dr Carlson requested the
resources to conduct one more cross-test
but this request was denied a member of
the o5 council affixed a request simply
saying stop it Carlson please stop it
Carlson get some help stop it Carl
Wilson document 10 revised entry oh
right the time SCP-173 literally caused
an XK Class end of the world scenario in
the document revised entry we get a
frightening glimpse into a possible
future world where SCP-173 develops a
terrifying new anomalous ability
multiplication we don't know exactly how
it happened but here the sculpture
somehow developed the ability to make
exact copies of itself and what's more
every time one of these copies is
produced the collective SCP-173 hive
mind gets stronger allowing them to
think tactically and slowly wipe out
North America even destroying any
potential Foundation countermeasures
then ripping and snapping through anyone
or anything that dared opposed in the
end the world decided to take the
nuclear option literally and blow away
North America with nuclear bombardment
in order to stop the SCP-173 Army from
spreading to the rest of the world world
and killing everyone however this
attempt didn't actually work as scp-173s
were spotted in Wales over in the UK
leading to a second nuclear bombardment
it continued like this until there were
no human beings left to push the big red
button anymore and only the endless
Legions of SCP-173 remained there is one
bright side to this otherwise pretty
bleak situation though a group of around
150 scp-173s ganged up on scp-682 and
toured to shreds Somewhere Out There Dr
Carlson is probably smiling adapting to
sudden and unexpected changes is a core
tenant of human survival however
abruptly finding yourself trapped in an
apparently infinite extra dimensional
pocket dimension in the form of a
never-ending Ikea while that can take a
brief adjustment period to get used to
Callan hadn't even noticed for the first
few moments wandering through the aisles
aimlessly passing Isles of hemnis and
trisils all the assembled display pieces
of affordable flat pack Furniture it
would have been more exciting shopping
for all the accoutrements for his brand
new apartment if Callan wasn't being
perpetually reminded that he was moving
in there on his own it took him almost
20 minutes of walking through the row of
Ikea products for him to realize
something fell off he had hardly seen
anybody else around in fact the more he
thought about it there hadn't even been
any employees in their garish yellow
Polo shirts and blue pants at the front
of the store squinting off in the
distance Callan couldn't even see the
far wall of the store sure he knew Ikea
Outlets were big inside somewhere
between a supermarket and an industrial
warehouse but this place seemed to go on
forever figuring that he had unknowingly
stumbled out of the store proper and
into a large storage area Callan turned
around and started to try to retrace his
steps back to the entrance it was after
another 20 minutes of taking this
approach that things went from feeling
off to being overtly unsettling by the
time time that over an hour had passed
Kellen was starting to panic racing
through the seemingly unending store the
rubber soles of his sneakers squeaking
against the epoxy resin floor as he
yelled loudly for somebody anybody that
might hear him before longing the latest
victim to find themselves lost inside
scp-3008 was hitting the first
existential hurdle that came with being
trapped in the infinite Ikea Kellen sat
on a display couch a two-seated
solderhound with a shade Lounge in case
anyone was wondering he was curled up
into a ball knees tucked under his chin
as he gently started rocking himself
back and forth in a feudal attempt to
comfort himself it hadn't yet quite sunk
in just how trapped he was the thought
that he might starve to death amongst
the endless talk of soras and fjartigs
the stores now closed please exit the
building the sudden sound of a voice
startled Callan snapping him out of his
dread-filled Daydream enough to realize
the store now marker the lights had been
gradually dimming the longer he had
stayed creating an artificial night
within scp-3008 normally the sign of
another person after being isolated
would come as a relief but whoever had
spoken was nowhere to be seen a slow
shuffling moved around the sofa Callum
was sitting on until he finally called
out into the dark hello is anyone there
there was a pause the movement stopped
for an agonizingly quiet moment the
store is now closed please exit the
building the voice repeated as the
Unseen speaker stepped out of the
Shadows even in the low light the
creature was horrifying everything about
it was just wrong for a split second
Callum thought it might be an Ikea
employee was wearing the uniform after
all but the bodily proportions were all
off arms hanging nearly all the way down
to the floor hands and fingers enlarged
and elongated as for its face it didn't
have one the ordinary features were
almost missing and now it was running
right for him Callan leaped over the
back of the solderheim and ran his first
instinct was to get away and hide
checking over his shoulder he got inside
of the faceless creature dashing right
past the couch with enough Force to
knock it over in his startled State
looking out of the corner of his eye at
the encroaching staff member Callan
tripped over his feet and tumbled back
down to the hard floor the creature
loomed over him as he tried to crawl
towards a nearby aisle looking up at it
the staff member was reaching for him
its big disproportionate hand
outstretched trying to grab at Callan as
he lay there helplessly suddenly
something struck the faceless creature
someone barely visible in the dim lights
of the store had leaped down from the
shells of the aisle and swung a
makeshift weapon at the staff member as
it connected the creature reeled
stumbling over itself long enough for
the mystery assailant to take another
swipe at it their weapon compressor
would look like part of a curtain rail
with a pair of kitchen knives at one end
impaled the staff member ripping through
its bright yellow Ikea Polo and out on
the other side striding over to where
Callum was still laying on the floor all
struck by the display he just witnessed
the figure pulled back the hood of a
rudimentary cloak they were wearing
fashioned by hand out of an Aina curtain
fabric revealing herself with a Stern
serious look on her face the woman
reached a handout to Callan offering to
help him up rather than whatever that
faceless creature had wanted with him
it's okay I'm not gonna hurt you she
stated as she pulled him back to his
feet this is probably all pretty
confusing for you right still too
stunned to speak Callan just nodded yeah
it was for me too the woman replied we
don't have long until more staff show up
so you need to come with me and don't
ask questions okay seeing him not again
she took Helen's head and led him
through the dark recesses of the
infinite Ikea stealthily the pair of
them snuck through the aisles keeping
low and ducking down out of sight
whenever more of the staff lumbered into
their path until they had wandered
elsewhere clearing the way for them to
proceed kellen's new guides seemed to
instinctively know her way around the
layout of the sprawling Maze of flat
packed Swedish Furniture quietly urging
him to stay close offering him a hand up
when they climbed up shelving units
until finally they arrived at their
destination a warm glow emanated from
somewhere beyond a tall makeshift
barrier sofas and cabinets were stacked
on top of each other forming an
intricate wall around an area of
scp-3008 and right in the middle of this
rudimentary barricade was a large
two-door Pax fartle wardrobe it's back
missing doors inwards facing towards the
inner side of the blockade the guide
stepped into the incomplete wardrobe and
gave a specifically timed knock three
beats with the third following the first
two after a short pause from the other
side it sounded like something was being
hurledly removed from the wardrobe's
handles before the doors opened up to
allow her and Callan entry beyond the
outer wall this part of the infinite
Ikea look to have been converted into a
small town with a sign hanging above
that red decoration population 58 there
were even more people within most in
handmade clothing crafted out of scraps
of fabric along with the remnants of old
clothes from the outside world they'd
been cut off from some looked like they
were standing on guard carrying weapons
similar to the guide's weapon others
were sitting around together talking
casually under the light of the solafeta
floor lamps okay the guide's side
turning back to Callan we're safe now
that we're inside the wall so you can
talk again now ah thank you you replied
awkwardly for saving me I mean they'll
mention it she smiled for the first time
since they had met I'm sure you've got a
lot of questions so ask away I'll do my
best to answer as many as I can where am
Cohen's voice trailed off thinking of a
question he wanted to know the answer to
even more than where he was or what was
up with this place who are you the girl
smiled and offered him an outstretched
hand my name's Kia over the coming
months and with a lot of direction from
his new friend Kellen slowly started to
adjusting to living inside
scp-3008 the lifestyle was completely
different from what he was used to
before instead of renting or buying a
house or apartment the survivors had
established their own little settlements
using the copious amounts of Ikea
furniture around to construct homes for
themselves without access to money or
any need for it nobody was self-serving
either everyone chipped in and helped
each other out agreed to take on tasks
that would benefit their fellow
survivors there was a strong sense of
community inside all anyone had in the
infinite Ikea was each other they were
all in the same situation and surviving
it was made easier by cooperating Kia
took responsibility for showing Kellen
around teaching him all about life
inside
scp-3008 when he asked her why she was
so adamant about keeping an eye on him
she replied by telling him that when she
arrived she'd been scared and alone even
when the town of decoration had taken
her in Kia still needed to learn all the
basics on her own she admitted that she
wished somebody was there to teach her
and endeavored to do exactly that for
Callum she started by telling him what
the best time to head to the food court
was every day all the food in scp-3008
would somehow reappear meaning that
everyone could easily have their fill
and survive without having to hunt or
kill each other in order to eat Kia's
next lesson involved teaching Callum how
to use Ikea's stationery to leave subtle
but recognizable symbols around the
store so that if he was ever lost he
could find his way back to decoration
safely while avoiding the staff that's
the thing about living here she said
when we first arrived we all think we've
got nothing but this place has food
shelter tools everything we need we just
have to learn to use what it gives us as
time went on Callan found himself paired
up with Kia for patrols during the
daytime staff would wander aimlessly
around the store far more docile than
they were at night to make sure that
they were ready in the event of an
attack by the faceless creatures the
survivors mapped out the staff's
movements reporting back to their
settlements in case a large group of
them were wandering too close the more
they went out together the more Kellen
found himself eagerly looking forward to
being in Kia's company maybe it was just
because she was the first person he'd
met inside the infinite Ikea perhaps
because she had saved his life but there
was something about her that made him
feel a little less sad about being
trapped here a feeling that would soon
be cruelly ripped away it happened
during an otherwise normal Patrol Kia
and Callan were checking the aisles
keeping an eye on the staff and tallying
everyone they saw the lights were
starting to dim indicating that it would
soon be night again and the pair of them
agreed it was time to start heading back
to decoration that was until a sudden
screeching caught their attention what
the hell was that Callan whispered no
idea Kia replied could be someone miles
just arrived she gave a hand signal that
instructed calendar split up the pair of
them moved through parallel aisles
towards the source of the noise it
sounded like Stone scraping against the
floor the weight of concrete causing
whatever was being moved to generate a
grating eardrum piercing racket as he
moved silently through the now familiar
space of scp-3008 Kellen racked his
brain about what could be making a noise
like that there was nothing that heavy
or Made of Stone within Ikea at least
not that he had encountered even Kia had
looked surprised when first detecting
that sound she'd been in here for so
much longer so it was telling when even
she had no clue what had made it
suddenly the noise stopped quickly as it
had started followed by the call of a
familiar voice Callan come look at this
Kia called what is it he shouted back
trying to keep his voice low but audible
aware that staff might be nearby I don't
know some kind of statue I've never seen
anything like this in here before he was
cut off mid sentence a quick loud scrape
of concrete against the resin floor
followed by a blood curdling scream eyes
widening and horror worried for her
safety Kellen sprinted further down the
aisle frantically calling Kia's name as
he reached the nearest Corner the screen
stopped her cries didn't fade lowering
gradually then petering off instead her
voice just cut out abruptly with a
sickening muffled crack like the sound
of bone breaking beneath the skin
panting Kellen whipped around the corner
that's when he saw her lying on the
floor totally unnervingly still her head
was tilted at an unnatural angle the
bones of her neck misaligned as blood
dripped from her nose Kia's body was
lying at the feet of something Callan
had never seen since he arrived at the
infinite Ikea it was some kind of
sculpture constructed out of concrete
over a metal rebar skeleton with a crude
attempt to add spray paint over its
outer surface he had no idea that this
statue was often referred to as SCP 173
Otherwise Known simply as the sculpture
but then Callan was more focused on how
distraunt he felt that seeing Kia dead
on the floor he had never worked up
enough courage to tell her always worry
that it would make things weird between
them and now he'd never get the chance
again would never get to see her smile
as he took on the lessons that she
taught him about surviving in scp-3008
feeling his eyes while up Kellen blinked
away tears suddenly the sculpture shot
forward in the split second that his
eyes were closed Kellen staggered away
in shock and stumbled over landing on
his back on the floor as he went to get
up scp-3008 was inches away from him
having moved yet again of its own accord
carefully Kellen stood up making sure to
keep looking straight at the Sinister
statue it was getting clear what this
thing was doing that I couldn't move
while being observed sure enough as he
started to cautiously back away one step
at a time
SCP-173 stayed still frozen in place
reaching the corner his eyes stinging
desperate to Blink Callan took a deep
breath fixing his Gaze on the sculpture
for one moment longer until turning and
sprinting as fast as his legs would
allow Callum had a few short moments to
Blink sending his tears streaming down
his face behind him he could hear the
same oncoming sound of concrete scraping
heavily against the floor as the
sculpture gave Chase Callan rushed down
the aisles grabbing stacks of flat packs
off the store shelves and pulling them
onto the floor leaving piles upon piles
of mess behind him in a desperate
attempt to slow the oncoming statue down
why hadn't it killed him already perhaps
it was just playing with its food he
thought about trying to get back to
decoration wondering if maybe any of the
other surviving settlers had encountered
SCP-173 before but as he ran Callan
caught sight of some of the symbols he
and Kia had left around the store to
help them find their way around one of
them denoted that there were hiding
spots nearby and spurred him on to
change course in that direction he
couldn't leave the sculpture back to
town not if it could slaughter them all
in the blink of an eye finding a cramped
cupboard Callum climbed inside and shut
the door behind him with his knees
tucked under his chin he couldn't help
but remember the time he had arrived in
the infinite Ikea he had done almost the
exact same thing when he first
encountered a staff member he'd run and
his first instinct had been just to run
away and hide that was something about
Kia he had always wished he could be she
was Fearless easily standing up to that
staff creature that would have killed
Callan if she hadn't intervened trapped
inside a cupboard the deafening noise of
scraping concrete outside as the
sculpture searched for him Callan felt
like he'd let her down it seemed that
despite Kia's best efforts to teach him
he was still scared as he sat in the
dark praying the sculpture wouldn't find
him he apologized under his breath to
her Callum started replaying every
moment he and Kia had spent together
partly to keep her alive in his memory
but also that he could at least think of
something good before
SCP-173 found him and broke his neck the
same way every lesson about life in
scp-3008 every one of Kia's skills she
had painstakingly passed on were still
all fair including the best piece of
advice she'd ever given we have to learn
to use with this place gives us her
words echoed in his head as Callum
finally realized that she hadn't just
been talking about taking food from the
food court or using flat packs to build
shelters and settlements she'd shown him
how to navigate how to evade the staff
and that everything in the infinite Ikea
could have some usefulness in aiding
survival as much as it heard knowing Kia
was gone Kellen realized that she might
have already saved him a second time he
peeked out of the cupboard door the
bathroom section was just a quick Dash
away and SCP-173 was nowhere to be seen
a few moments later the sculpture
detected a loud sound someone knocking
things together shouting and whooping
had caught its attention unobserved the
concrete creature Zapped its way towards
the source of the commotion moving
quickly over towards the bathroom
Department of the store's endless aisles
it came to a sudden instinctive stop
sensing Eyes Were Watching it its entire
Stone body froze rigidly fixed to the
spot it was standing on it didn't matter
that the eyes watching at this time were
its own reflected back at itself in an
assortment of mirrors
SCP-173 was stuck someone had sprung a
trap for the Statue making it so that
from the moment it shot over to its
current position it wouldn't be able to
move it was constantly being observed by
itself no matter what angle Its
Reflection would be within its own
direct line of sight standing atop a
nearby stack of shelves Calvin looked
down at the concrete statue trapped in a
collection of mirrors that he had
assorted into a ring hey you he called
down at it hoping it could hear him even
though was frozen in place the store is
now closed please exit the building he
struck loudly against the metal frame of
the shelves hoping it was loud enough to
be heard sure enough the staff quickly
descended on the source of the noise the
Knight made the staff feral hostile
towards anything they sensed to be an
outside presence they instantly honed in
on SCP-173 attacking it to little veil
thanks to its Stone body eventually the
group of Staff grew a number starting to
heave the sculpture as they went to
remove it from the premises climbing
from shelf to shelf Khan followed them
the entire way the staff had no eyes so
technically couldn't look at SCP-173 but
he could even through tears he didn't
blink until the sculpture had been
removed he wanted to make sure it was
what Kia would have done the year was
1994 and all seemed well at site 19.
researchers administrative staff
containment Specialists and gar saw to
their daily tasks as the largest SCP
Foundation containment site on the books
there was something paradoxically
prestigious and pedestrian about working
at the legendary facility of course
among staff at the SCP Foundation the
site was famous and took on a certain
mythology around break room discussions
for those who weren't assigned there did
you see the crazy new tech they got at
site 19. it's like something out of Star
Wars I heard some of the anomalies they
store at site 19 can cause XK Class end
of the world scenarios so they've got
hammer down on speed dial you know my
buddy told me that site 19 has a pool on
the fifth floor everyone who works there
gets to go up and chill there once a
week and they've got a dedicated bar up
there that serves cocktails with little
umbrellas all night long of course some
rumors are truer than others not the
pool thing though sorry that one's
complete baloney it is however
completely true of the SCP explained
office but hey that's story for another
day site 19 as a result of its size does
indeed need a simultaneously large and
Elite staff to handle its many unique
containment requirements people work
around the clock to ensure everything
runs smoothly knowing that the risk of
dropping the ball means death and
destruction on a wide scale Personnel
have been trained to meticulously study
new anomalies discover their strengths
and weaknesses drum up ideal containment
requirements and get the situation on
mock as quickly as possible most of the
time the operations at site 19 run
smoother than George Benson most of the
time of course with the exception of a
few researchers there sorry Dr Brighton
Dr Crow everyone who works at site 19 is
only human mistakes can happen even when
the cost of those mistakes is much
costlier than when you forget to carry
the little zero on your dull office jobs
latest mind-numbing spreadsheet little
oversights can pile up into catastrophes
over time especially when you put your
mind to committing the greatest sin of
all underestimating your opponent
exactly as the SCP Foundation did one
fateful day in 1994. you see the SCP
Foundation contains hundreds if not
thousands of new anomalies every single
year when this job becomes your daily
bread and butter what once seemed
exceptionally slow becomes humdrum and
mundane just like the earlier rumors
suggested there are monsters entities
and objects locked up at site 19 that
could cause an XK Class end of the world
scenario if they ever got out could the
fine folks Staffing that site really be
blamed for not paying that much
attention to some anomalous sculpture
they just weren't aware how incredibly
dire the consequences of taking your
eyes off of SCP-173 were yet but believe
me when I say they were about to receive
a hell of an education the sculpture had
come into their care a year earlier in
1993 though the exact circumstances of
how it came to site 19 tend to differ
depending on who you ask its anomalous
ability had become apparent rather
quickly at the expense of a few careless
personnel's lives but hey isn't that
always the way these things unfold the
sculpture could be frozen in place by
looking at it though whenever people
turn their gaze away it moved towards
its prey at shocking speeds and killed
them by either strangulation or more
commonly snapping necks sure it wasn't
the kind of entity you'd want to have a
cup of coffee with or place in your
living room as a striking new object dot
but the foundation had plenty of these
so-called murder monsters in containment
already and this was one you didn't even
need to shoot just looking at it is
enough to freeze it in place a few
d-classes were lost during the first few
months to figuring out the best way to
clean the nasty creature's cell on
account of the fact that it poops
constantly but other than that it was
all pretty smooth sailing they had no
idea just how dangerous this work of
malicious Modern Art was
this brings us back to that fateful day
in 1994. the day when
SCP-173 first breached containment
researcher Theo Trask was walking down
the large winding Halls of site 19
marking off each successfully contained
anomaly on his clipboard it was a
monotonous job but somebody had to do it
he looked through the viewing windows of
all the anomalies that wasn't deadly to
look at taking inventory he worked at
the SCP Foundation for eight years now
and nothing amazed him anymore he was
thinking about what he might have for
dinner that night or whether he should
go to the movie theater to see that new
film Pulp Fiction up in the security
office for sector C of site 19 security
officer Todd Buffett and his men
observed the monitors glowing before
them it was a blissfully boring day one
of them was discreetly playing snake on
his Nokia under the table days like this
were made for wasting and they were
tragically few at the SCP Foundation
where being excited was often the
prelude for being dead Todd yawned and
was happy for the privilege to do so in
a darkened sector C server room a group
of Engineers performed routine
maintenance they could see their breath
these rooms were kept extra cold to
prevent the technology from overheating
it was intricate work but they were well
trained to do it so much so that they
sometimes slipped into a state of
autopilot while conducting these checks
saving the burden of conscious thought
for meteor tasks further down the line
these were unremarkable tasks on an
unremarkable day and they would be happy
for it all to end and of course it would
just not in the sense that they meant a
mixed group of researchers and
administrative staff sat in the break
room enjoying their mediocre packed
lunch and sharing their own version of
inane office banter it was a nice step
away from the often deadly grind and
shoot the breeze with of others in their
line of work after all it was a strange
job with its own unique pressures you
needed to discuss it with others who got
it sometimes just to avoid going insane
from the pressure but then you needed to
avoid the unforgivable blade of this
double-edged swords mirror half you
never wanted to get too attached to a
co-worker at the SCP Foundation because
who knows
you might not be seeing them again
tomorrow or they might not be seeing you
back in the surfer Bank a junior
technician named Colin Muntz was about
to make one teeny tiny little mistake
while running Diagnostics on one of the
room's power cores he tripped a fuse and
set a terrible chain reaction in motion
cables running all through psych 19
caught the shockwaves of Colin's poor
decision in a moment causing a series of
power cuts that ran through different
systems throughout the facility each one
tripping the next like proverbial series
of tumbling dominoes back to researcher
Theo Trask lazily ticking boxes on his
clipboard he was about to do another one
and break for lunch when the lights
overhead suddenly went out leaving him
in a dark hallway he was immediately
broken from his trance heart beating 20
to the Dozen seconds passed and the dark
somehow remain what was going on here it
didn't make sense surely the auxiliary
generator should have kicked in by now
right and on any other day it would have
but unluckily for Theo Trask this just
so happened to be the one day in the
last several months that the facility's
main backup generator was also
experiencing routine maintenance
sometimes life just isn't fair Trask
felt his heart leap up into his throat
as a door somewhere behind him slowly
creaked open with a torturously long
metallic Screech Trask didn't have a gun
or even a taser but he did have a small
flashlight attached to his belt with a
draw speed that would rival Clint
Eastwood in this Prime the terrifying
Trask whipped out his flashlight and
Shone it in the direction of the noise
his being caught a static figure staring
at him without a face the rigid soulless
body of the sculpture
SCP-173 was standing less than 10 feet
away from him in this light it smears of
krylon-based spray paint looked almost
like a mocking grin your move
seem to say Trask had broken into a cold
sweat his hand was shaking but he needed
to keep the beam on that monster
whatever trip the power must have
compromised the system that governed the
sculpture's electrical deadbolt and
unless the light bulbs came back on and
the hallway was suddenly flooded with
other personnel and a forklift to get
that miserable chunk of concrete back
into its cell then he was in real
trouble he couldn't run it would kill
him the second he turned around and he
couldn't walk backwards one trip in the
dark and he'd be found dead on the
ground head facing in the wrong
direction all he could do now was Ho
hope and of course not blank but as the
seconds passed and the pressure mounted
this became harder and harder to achieve
he could feel the surface of his eyes
drying out leading to a sharp stinging
sensation still the sculpture lingered
and waited as researcher trasks eyes
began to water people should be coming
shouldn't they surely help would way but
he couldn't hear footsteps or the
squeaking tires of a forklift just yet
he couldn't hear anything except his
heartbeat and the blood rushing in his
ears his eyes were killing him just
metaphorically for now but not for long
what harm would one little blink do only
for a fraction of a second now before we
proceed to the researchers gruesome and
terrifying death we'd like to perform a
quick experiment with you the viewer of
SCP explained we've created a number of
videos exploring the fascinating and
frightening Enigma of SCP-173 and one
statement seems to pop up in the
comments again and again from back seat
containment experts man why not just
blink your eyes one at a time that's a
Surefire way to keep it locked into
place okay then let's give it a try open
both your eyes nice and wide now blink
your left eye and now blink your right
left right left right keep keep going
while I'm talking don't stop keep it up
how are your eyes feeling it makes your
vision a little blurry doesn't it kind
of makes your eyes sting a little as
time goes on oh look who it is well if
it is an SCP-173 what a surprise and it
looks very interested in you doesn't it
better keep one of your eyes open at all
times left blink right blink left blink
right blink no pressure of course but if
you've closed your eyes at any time
during this little experiment you're
already laying dead on the ground with a
broken neck left right left right do you
feel the burn yet there's no shame in
giving up all it'll cost you is your
life and that's why we don't blink one
eye at a time now
back to the story researcher Trask
couldn't take it any longer his aching
eyes fluttered clothes for an almost
imperceptible moment of time and that
was all this Sinister sculpture needed
Trask felt the impossibly cold concrete
grip of its stubby arms on either side
of his head and a sharp jerk that
communicated the mere moment of
unimaginable pain followed by the
physical answer to silence the sculpture
darted through the darkness of the
hallway with no living eyes left to
freeze it in place in the darkness it
was impossible to defeat it would do the
two things it knew how to do hunt and
murder in the sector C Security Office
all hell was breaking loose thanks to
Colin muntz's little oopsie in the
server room all the monitors were dark
and all the corded phones that had given
them a direct line to assistance were
all dead they had no idea what was
happening out there maybe they had all
gotten extremely unlucky and all of the
cells were open whatever caused this
catastrophic power failure must have
also knocked out the alarm system
because they were getting
when the door behind security officer
Todd Buffett and his men opened he was
profoundly relieved to think that
assistance had already arrived he and
his men were a lot less relieved when
they began to fall to the ground their
necks snapped with exquisite efficiency
if you're into that kind of thing that's
because the sculpture had found its way
into the security office and gave itself
more crunch than you'd get from a
family-sized bag of Doritos but with
these new victims now little more than
dead meat it was time to move on over in
the break room the collection of
research and Administration staff who
were enjoying Pleasant Chit Chat not
long ago were Now hidden away in
darkness it was so Bleak in there that
they couldn't see the cup of ramen
steaming inches away from their faces in
moments like this the usual advice is to
stay calm and wait for the situation to
be resolved after all if you tried to
take anything into your own hands you
might fall over and injure yourself
normally this is good advice it's less
effective when the thing that wishes you
grave injury is actively on its way and
sitting in the dark certainly isn't
going to stop it elsewhere in the
building the engineering team were
scrambling like there was no tomorrow to
rectify their mistake partially because
of SCP-173 got to them before they'd
gotten the lights working again there
really would be no tomorrow with their
mini flashlights they desperately search
for any way to rectify the issue and get
everything turned back on in a normal
company the biggest concern in the
situation like this might be massive
irretrievable data loss but of course at
the SCP Foundation the issue is more a
massive and irretrievable loss of human
life and also the data too a few miles
south of site 19 a different kind of
Cavalry were on its way a Detachment of
MTF new 7 hammer down were on their way
in a pair of armored helicopters their
assault rifles had flashlights fixed to
them and their helmets came fitted with
night vision goggles as standard there
Intel suggested a large portion of
site-19 sector C had gone dark for
whatever reason and they were ready to
drop in and get things back under
control the one question was whether
they'd get there in time to save the
people in the break room as the
sculpture Drew ever closer to their
location speaking of the group of
research and Administration staff were
still just sitting around waiting for
the lights to turn back on one of the
more senior researchers in the room Dr
Sherry bruis was a lifelong smoker and
as such she was fishing around in her
purse for her Zippo lighter to shed some
light on the situation her rummaging was
so loud that she could barely even hear
the door to the room beginning to Creak
open but she heard the first snap and
the awful animalistic chorus of Screams
that followed crunch crunch crunch as
each of her fellow members of foundation
Personnel fell she could feel the thing
killing them getting closer she could
almost feel the same icy limbs gripping
her skull when she whipped out and lit
the Zippo the flame coming alive in
front of her face with the pleasing
metallic click it didn't offer much
light just enough for her to see the
Monster looming inches away from her
face
SCP-173 limbs outstretched and ready the
rest of the room was silent she knew in
that moment she was the only one alive
in here now but she still wasn't the
only Survivor yet that all depended on
what happened next the flame danced and
the sculpture remained Frozen in place
standing so close to her it wanted her
it wanted to hear her neck crunch the
Flames began to dance erratically and Dr
bruis felt her heart rate Spike one
careless breath and the light keeping
her alive would be gone but even if she
did everything right here it might not
be enough to save her it didn't even
need a second to do what it wanted so
badly to do the light it seemed almost
to flicker getting smaller getting
weaker Dr Bruce felt tears dribbling
down her cheeks any second now click the
lights above her turn back on she could
have screamed in Delirious relief but
that might have also been a scream at
the expense of her many dead co-workers
littered around the room either way her
thoughts were interrupted by a staccato
burst of footsteps followed by the boom
of the door being kicked in by a booted
foot the members of hammerdown were
standing in the doorway she was saved in
the hours that followed things were
righted as best as they could be with so
many deaths the sculpture was returned
to containment the bodies were cleared
away the electrical issues were fixed
much would continue on as normal after
that day death after all was an
occupational hazard for those working at
the SCP Foundation but one thing forever
changed
SCP-173 was never underestimated again
bodies all over the ground next Twisted
faces contorted in Terror
SCP-173 not one but an army scatters out
through site 19 massacring researchers
one broken neck at a time pure chaos how
could this possibly have happened the
strobing of the blood red emergency
lighting was already fear-inducing
enough so it was being hidden under one
of the tables in the mess hall trembling
as the noise of alarms rang out through
the facility but the thing about the
flickering light scared SCP Foundation
researcher Mira Smithy all the more were
the few seconds of Darkness that came
between each flash of red if it had been
any other Containment Breach she
probably wouldn't have even noticed for
in those few seconds when the warning
light lit up only to cut out she
couldn't see a thing and her not being
able to see made it easier for them to
move around Mira had lost track of time
since the alarms had first sounded to
Mark the Containment Breach she tried to
keep count of the minutes of the
drumming of her heartbeat had thrown her
off there was no way of knowing if it
had been hours or only a few minutes
since everything went wrong of course
the SCP Foundation had plenty of
procedures and protocols in place to
prevent or respond to situations like
this yet the emergency alarms kept
echoing through the corridors lights
plunging the facility Into Darkness
every few seconds only to break it up
with a brief flash of red it seemed to
mirror from her hiding spot that this
breach had proven far too much for the
foundation's extensive procedures to
counteract maybe it was all over already
she thought after a few seconds or maybe
minutes under the table what if they had
gotten bored tired of slaughtering their
way through Foundation personnel and
slunk back to their containment chamber
that would have been simpler far less
terrifying than the alternative that
came creeping into Mira's head in the
form of her next thought what if she was
the only one left alive a last member of
site Personnel still breathing just by
some random hundred to one chance and if
that was the case how long would it take
for them to find her how many even were
there a new sound just detectable below
the alarms broke through her Avalanche
of anxious questions
footsteps the noise of boots clomping
against the floor clearly belonging to a
human and not one of them cautious as to
which way her gaze was directed Mira
poked her head from out beneath the
table glancing around during the few
seconds where the red of the emergency
lights allowed her to see the steps were
getting closer and as they did
researcher Smithy realized something
that made her fearful for her fellow
Survivor they were running away and
there was no way they could do that
while also looking back at what was
coming after them over here she hissed
in a hush tone at the sight of a pair of
legs crossing a nearby Corridor their
thick standard issue military boots
seemed to match those worn by the
Foundation security Personnel the
officer passed by only to stop and
tiptoe closer to the mess hall having
heard Mira's whispered call with the red
lights blinking it looked like every
other step the security officer took had
been edited out like they were
teleporting closer in the dark watching
intently from her Hiding Place reminded
Meera sickeningly of the things she was
hiding from how they moved and the
worrying fact that she couldn't see one
following the security officer hello
hello other man's voice as he entered
the mess hall under the table we were
whispered if we hide we can still see
them but they can't see us hiding he
replied now we need something I can
revert these things back to the original
how so much easier to handle when there
was just one of them look let's make a
break for it I'm gonna grab scp-3108 and
get the lights back on if we can restore
visibility we might be able to stand a
fighting chance against those things the
officer was looking around the cafeteria
trying to locate the source of
researcher smithy's voice eyes
distracted then the intermittent
flickering of red light cut off again
plunging the entire mess hall into near
pitch Darkness at the same time there
was the sound of something heavy and
stoned scraping against the flooring it
turned Mira's stomach and she
immediately covered her mouth she had no
idea if they could hear her breathing
could a creature of stone even detect
sound at all well the lights were down
and the security guard's back was turned
a pair of sculptures built from concrete
and rebar traces of spray paint over
their Stone skin appeared behind the
officer at impossible speed there was a
sickening crunch followed by the sound
of something dropping to the floor of
the mess hall as the emergency lights
flicked back on Mira see them the two
copies of SCP-173 standing still next to
the table she was under bathed in red
light this nightmare had all begun as an
otherwise ordinary Friday for the SCP
Foundation only a few hours earlier Mira
had been brainstorming her latest pitch
for a series of experiments involving
scp-914 otherwise known as the
Clockworks scp-914 was a large machine
comprised of various cogs Gyros and
gears of Unknown Origin its function
however had long been documented and was
of great interest to the foundation any
object placed with an scp-914's input
Booth could be transformed destroyed or
improved depending on the clockworks's
setting rough would disintegrate the
subject course would dismantle it to its
base components and one-to-one would
merely replace the object with a similar
almost identical one then there were the
fine and very fine settings the former
would cause scp-914 to improve and any
item and the later is capable of the
same but with one key difference very
fine would refine an object even more
usually by giving it anomalous
properties the foundation higher-ups had
permitted staff to freely conduct tests
using the Clockworks although approval
was required and all data was to be
recorded while many of the scientists at
the foundation were fixed on the
mysterious origin of scp-914 or the
furthest extent of its refinement
capabilities Myra had been thinking
about it in a far more practical way she
wasn't interested in the how or the why
of scp-914's inner workings nor who had
built it her experiments were born out
of considering better usages for the
Clockworks it was a machine that could
provide endless possibilities and Myra
was determined to make it to the fullest
use of it in order to solve actual real
world problems imagine for a moment she
announced reading off her cue cards as
she practiced pitching her experiment to
the foundation's senior researchers
imagine in a world where nobody ever
gets sick where human beings are able to
live long healthy and prosperous lives
maybe dial back on the Star Trek her
colleague research assistant Jensen
interjected really that's what you call
constructive criticism she retorted
before continuing if we apply the
transformative refinement powers of
scp-914 that world could be the future
that awaits us for example I'm proposing
tests that involve placing man-made
chemical compounds like painkillers
heart medication and other potentially
life-saving medicines through the
Clockworks refinement process I'm not
suggesting we need to set it to very
fine and create anomalous versions of
these things but what if even on the
fine setting we're able to improve the
effectiveness of our existing treatments
for all kinds of afflictions Jensen
raised their hand patiently waiting to
comment like a child in a classroom what
a few things they replied lowering their
hand first off some if not all man-made
medications include some kind of organic
component the o5 council have Vandal yes
I'm fully aware of the containment
procedures Mira interrupted them that's
exactly why I'm trying to convince the
council or how just even Dr bright to
let me step around I genuinely believe
we could be doing so much more with
scp-914 and I need them to see that look
I'm not here to rain on your parade
Smithy her assistant reassured I'm only
bringing up concerns that anyone will
have about this proposal you talked
about wanting to improve our existing
Medical Treatments which is Noble don't
get me wrong but have you considered the
wider effect that might have if you make
everyone on Earth more resistance or
even immune to everything then diseases
are going to evolve what if we end up
with a form of super bacteria resistant
to all forms of medication even if that
medicine's been refined in scp-914
trying to save the world might just
bring about its end I've thought about
that but if the council starts allowing
for biological testing again then the
solution is obvious we use the
Clockworks to eradicate whatever germs
diseases are able to develop after
improving treatment options Myra
explained then adding besides that can't
be any more dangerous than what we've
been using As cp914 for I mean enhancing
other scps that's a recipe for disaster
got to agree with you there Jensen said
even without placing them in the
Clockworks the foundation's been way too
Cavalier with the Dangerous Ones
speaking of you know what tonight is
Smithy replied with a confused look date
night they stated elsewhere in the
facility a known to researcher Smithy at
that time one of the dangerous scps
Jensen had mentioned had been let out of
containment this was a regular
occurrence even if it was considered a
little unorthodox to some in fact the
only reason that the o5 council so often
turned a blind eye to it was because of
the researcher it involved Dr alto clef
it seemed clef had a certain fondness
for SCP-173 the sculpture a living
statue constructed from concrete and
rebar that could travel at impossible
speeds whenever it was unobserved most
Friday nights clef would have romantic
candlelit dinners with SCP-173 putting a
dress and blonde wig on the sculpture
and treating it like his beloved partner
the whole while watched by Dr clef and a
group of d-class acting as waiters and
Cooks
SCP-173 would stand motionless while the
bizarre date went on late into the night
it was no secret that the sculpture was
a highly aggressive creature with a
penchant for snapping the neck of the
nearest person the moment that they
blinked however it was only because of
Dr clef's reputation and track record
for the elimination of anomalies that he
was granted the special privilege of
whining and dining with SCP-173 this
time though partway through their
regularly scheduled date Dr cleff was
called away to deal with matters
relating to another anomaly he'd been
charged with decommissioning the pair of
d-class waiting on the doctor and his
date were instructed to wait keep a
close eye on SCP-173 alerting each other
in case they needed to Blink it was a
hell of a gamble a risk that could have
been avoided if the sculpture had been
transported back to its secure
containment chamber but Dr clef could be
persuasive that is to say he threatened
both d-class Waiters with the
bludgeoning from his ukulele if they
didn't do as he asked both the d-classes
stared directly at the sculpture each
one feeling the anxious beads of sweat
slowly crawling down their foreheads
worried that they'd both blink at the
same time by accident they announced
their need to refresh their eyes every
so often alternating between being The
Watcher and the one allowed to Blink all
the while as cp-173 was motionless
perhaps it was patiently waiting for Dr
clef to return or for one of the d-class
watching to slip up as if through some
cruel twist of fate a fly began to buzz
through the air drifting towards the
d-class with their eyes on SCP-173 it
looped and darted around its wings
making an annoying droning one of the
waiters announced he needed to Blink
again and the other told him he was free
to do so while he kept watch over the
sculpture at the exact same moment that
one man blinked the Flies zipped its way
towards the second d-class distracting
him again and drawing his gaze for a
little more than a millisecond that fly
whizzing past was the last thing he saw
as SCP-173 darted forward it moved with
such incredible speed that it was
imperceptible grabbing the nearby
d-class the one who'd spotted the fly
and killing him instantly before the
other could even open his eyes when he
did SCP-173 had vanished from its spot
at the date night table nowhere to be
seen before the remaining d-class could
realize it was behind him
SCP-173 had made short work of its other
Observer it began zipping unseen through
the corridors of the SCP Foundation
facility Dr clef had returned to his
date only to find the two d-class
waiters dead and SCP-173 missing
immediately he had raised the alarm
meaning that research staff were too
busy fleeing to safely pay any attention
to the sculpture quickly making its way
through the site swept up in the
evacuation Half deaf and by the alarms
in all the commotion researcher Myra
Smithy hadn't even realized she left the
door to the Clockworks wide open
shuffling down a corridor with her
fellow researchers the light suddenly
went out a few nearby screamed in panic
at having been unceremoniously thrust
into the dark Myra blindly reached for
Jensen's hand only to hear the sounds of
multiple heavy concrete feet dragging
along the floor suddenly the emergency
lights blinked she turned and to her
horror she saw SCP-173 with its Stony
arms around Jensen's neck their face
stricken with sheer Terror Tears in
their eyes but now Myra quickly realized
as the corridor was filled with shrieks
of fear from the other researchers that
there was more than one sculpture now
Myra barely managed to escape with her
life and all the confusion crawling out
of the low-lit corridor on her hands and
knees while the multiple new SCP-173
instances slaughtered anyone that
couldn't see them since then she had
been hiding hearing the scraping steps
of the sculptures traveling around the
facility unobserved they had attacked
the fuse boxes first as if in a
calculated tactical move take out the
lights and suddenly everyone found it
much harder to see them even through the
fear it was hard for Mira not to blame
herself for all the chaos she couldn't
remember whether she'd left the door to
scp-914 open or not but it hadn't taken
her long to figure out that the
Clockworks had something to do with this
madness somehow SCP-173 had made its way
there had been able to operate the
Machinery while the foundation staff
were distracted by their own evacuation
presumably with scp-914 set to very fine
the sculpture had been transformed into
its ultimate refined form or multiple
forms it seemed there was a veritable
horde of scp-173s running amok through
the facility it made sense Myra reasoned
in some Twisted cruel anomalous way the
sculpture had only ever been a danger
when unobserved the second anyone took
their eyes off of it so much has blinked
it would strike how does a machine like
scp-914 improve upon that easy it gives
the sculpture the power to replicate
itself anyone can look at multiple
things at once of course but nobody can
look at everything simultaneously even
if someone was watching a pair or three
scp-173s one more could easily slip up
behind them for the kill still hidden
under the table Myra's eyes were locked
on the pair of sculptures in the mess
hall the body of the security officer
out of focus in her peripheral vision
she dared not look away Frozen in sheer
fear that the second she blinked they
would lift up the table and find her she
had been so overwhelmed so paralyzed
with her Terror that she had forgotten
about the lights as the emergency
lighting flickered again the sculptures
both moved shifting across the mess hall
as the room went dark only to stop in
place the second Myra could see them
again they hadn't gotten closer in fact
both looked to be leaving the only thing
keeping them here was her she was
watching them and it had Frozen them in
place their greatest strength the
imperceptible movement and speed of
SCP-173 was offset by an indisputable
weakness of their anomalous biology they
couldn't stop someone from looking at
them and couldn't stop themselves
becoming still solid concrete when they
were being watched mulling over her
options Myra decided to follow through
with the plan from the Fallen security
guard to retrieve
scp-3108 and try to undo what the
Clockworks had done slowly she slipped
out from under the table keeping both
eyes on the pair of sculptures keeping
them lashed to one spot as she gradually
backed out of the mess hall the lights
went out and plunged the area Into
Darkness again and researcher Smithy
could hear the heavy concrete scraping
of the two sculptures looking for her as
she blindly made her way through the
facility she managed to evade the
roaming Stone creatures resisting her
natural instinct to hide and looking
directly at any she encountered on the
way making sure to stay out of their
view if she saw them she'd freeze them
if they saw her they'd chase her
eventually fishing scp-3108 out of a
containment box Myra held the weapon in
her hand it was a heavily modified Nerf
gun which she loaded a foam dart into
and pulled the plastic slide back the
creatively named nerfing gun had almost
the opposite effect of scp-914 instead
of improving Something
scp-310a Turned whatever was shot with
it into an inferior equivalent object
something worse than itself it just
might work drawing the gun as she heard
the sound of scraping concrete getting
nearer and nearer Myra turned the corner
coming face to face with one of the
sculptures she held the gun High closing
the gap between them making sure she
didn't miss but wary she needed to fire
before the lights blinked off again she
squeezed the plastic trigger sending the
foam darts shooting out of the barrel of
the nerfing gun the flimsy projectile
guided with the SCP-173 instance
bouncing off its head and landing on the
floor for a split second the light
dimmed again then came back on Myra's
heart had lurched in her chest only to
see that the sculpture hadn't moved at
all she leaned closer to it blinking
intentionally it still didn't move it
was rooted to the ground fixed just a
statue rendered powerless by the nerfing
gun excitedly Myra knelt down and
scrabbled on the floor to retrieve the
dart just as the emergency lighting
flickered out again in her excitement
Myra was too focused on reloading as
cp3108 that is until she heard the
shuffling of concrete and rebar behind
her the lights were still out and she
fumbled blindly for the foam dart as the
noise got closer and closer her
fingertips brushed the projectile
knocking it further away when suddenly
the lights came back up but as she
reached for it researcher Smithy felt a
large cold presence behind her something
huge and heavy and made of stone and
lingering at the very corner of her eye
before she could turn around and face it
something and grabbed Myra and a
sickening snap rang out through the
corridor being on SCP-173 detail isn't
easy these duties of strict observation
fall on a bi-weekly basis when scp-173's
enclosure needs to be cleaned the
reddish-brown substance on the floor is
a natural output of SCP-173 a
combination of feces and blood while the
foundation has put up with a lot of
depraved behavior from its scps it draws
the line at poor hygiene they routinely
send in a crew of three d-class
personnel to clean up the mess but the
bigger chore isn't the scrubbing and
mopping at all but rather keeping
SCP-173 docile to do so the line of
sight must not be broken at any time
with SCP-173 Personnel assigned to enter
the container are instructed to alert
one another before blinking if this
protocol is not followed as cp-173
attacks by snapping the neck at the base
of the skull it is at its core
a high-stakes staring contest the crew
is intelligently divided into their
tasks only one of them actually has
janitorial duties and even then the
moppers most relevant skill isn't even
related to cleaning at all his greatest
strength must be his ability to trust
other people as he takes his mop to the
floor he hands over his life to his crew
who protect him with their focus and
attention on SCP-173 it is without a
doubt one of the cruelest and most
stressful jobs anyone could ever have
but not every horror story is found in
the trenches of Terror those with mops
on the front lines have their work cut
out for them but even the researchers
with their warm lab coats and boring
bureaucratic obligations aren't safe
from danger this is the story of Jake
skull a researcher who for reasons we
will tactfully tease you with until the
video's witty end has been reassigned to
SCP-173 director Fordham brought the bad
news like a bag of coal you're being
reassigned he said with a slight smirk
on his face continuing to be preoccupied
with his paperwork as if this news was
secondary to what he was doing right
there and then but it wasn't secondary
to Jack skull it was the center of their
life no not even just the center it was
The Sinner peripheral and outer bounds
of their life their assignments were
everything and everything was about to
change a pregnant silence followed the
announcement Jake's skull couldn't find
a response and they weren't even sure
there was one to be found no matter how
deep they dug what came out wasn't as
much of a retort as a reaction that
involuntary bodily response to events
that weren't expected that awkward and
Afraid muttering of fear and confusion
ah I
what I am I'm being where
aha I I'm to be reassigned is that what
you're saying researcher skull blinked a
few times confused their feet sunk into
the deep forest green shag on the floor
a spectrum of thoughts cascaded through
their mind as they searched harder and
harder for a reason digging deeper and
deeper only to find another Treasure
Chest full of nothing is my work not
sufficient on SCP director Fordham
looked up and gave them the fixed
pointed stair they'd grown to dread over
the past six months of course not Jake I
recognize what you've done and we want
to put you somewhere I feel you deserve
and serve the foundation of course we're
putting you on a very important and
special object again Fordham gave that
smirk that damn smirk sure his words and
tone presented themselves as the truth
but his face said otherwise the devious
positioning of his lip suggested that
there was a layer of sin subtext to his
speech but Jake schole couldn't pick up
on the cues there's no room to read
someone else's poker face when all of
your attention is on the crappy hand
you've just been dealt Jake skull's eyes
fell to the desk reassigned the word
rang like church bells why God their
work with scp-3872 as a Consulting
chemist was going slowly to be truthful
but they didn't think it was to the
point that they needed reassignment ah
all right which project am I assigned to
the time between the question and the
answer was the longest of Jake's life
the uncertainty felt like an eternity
Fordham tapped a few symbols accessing
skull's profile and added an entry in
their security clearance he hastily
swiped away all the other files listed
and turned back to face skull you have
access to it now please get on the first
plane to site 19. your dormitory
contents are already packed up Jake
reached into their pocket to check the
notification on their cell phone
scp-3872 file removed
scp-2593 file removed
SCP-173 file added they turned around
and walked slowly through the corridors
towards the Transportation Hub on the
outskirts of the site they open the file
on their phone and quickly scanned the
oddly phrased report attempting to make
sense of what they were reading skull's
eyebrows raised to the heavens as they
noticed the timestamp on containment
SCP-173 was one of the first one of the
few objects that the foundation came to
possess through some organization or
another without losing its information
they tried their best to remain
optimistic in their interpretation of
these new life events and for a moment
they thought this might be a good thing
for me swiping down they came to the
section about assigned researchers the
people whose steps they would be
following in and where were those steps
leading them the list was impressive
from Dr draki to Dr bright these people
were all legends in their own right and
so if they could just follow their
footsteps they reason they would end
their journey in a good place they
imagine their new career path straight
to the top of this mountain of success
maybe they would become the face of the
foundation maybe they would accomplish
so much that they'd had a statue erected
in their honor that people travel far
and wide to visit and take pictures with
maybe this would be a good thing they
wanted to think I need the first plane
to site 19 they said with confidence
I've been reassigned and so Jake skull
took to the air and clung to the stream
as long as they could but no matter how
heavy a sleeper reality shakes everyone
awake eventually six years later Jake
skull could hear the years pass but not
only could they hear it they could feel
it their body was decaying in a way
inconsistent with our biological
understanding of age
SCP-173 the legendary object the first
the original the statue it was chipping
away at the soul of Jake's skull it was
carving a statue of its own hacking at
Stone until it was nothing and that's
what Jake's skull felt like nothing it
was torture when they arrived they
quickly reviewed the research materials
every word had become burned into their
memory all 233 words of them the
additional research materials turned out
to be a few scribbled Pages by board
researchers a few had made hypotheses
that it all turned out to be nonsense
there was a locked filing cabinet but
every time skull requested it be opened
maintenance told them that the control
room was designated low priority and
they would get to it eventually over the
past six years Jake's skull had made 18
separate transfer requests they wanted
out but all of them had been denied it
was as if they were in high school again
asking dates to prom and getting hit
with no thank yous feeling none of the
politeness backed into their syntax
understanding only the brutal reality of
the phrase no they were stuck here
technically a level three staff now but
without any rights to view or work on
any other objects they were given a
promotion but it withheld all the perks
and benefits that come with it they were
stuck in a loop of pats on the back
people extended them their hand but it
was always with an empty Palm giving
them nothing to hold on to but a gesture
they were assigned a staff of four three
d-class all of which were older men and
a lazy level 2 security officer who
slouched in this office chair meeting
the bare minimum requirements to be
considered a living human being the
d-class were all quite docile they came
in once a week mopped the floor mumbled
clear to each other and left they lived
within this exact structure no new days
became an unspoken motto the these
recurring 24 hours pass slowly if there
were no clocks to prove the passing of
time they would have every reason to
believe it had frozen over but
occasionally ever so occasionally the
day would deviate just slightly they'd
hear something a scrape and the sounds
of movement Jake would flip open the
observation ports on the double concrete
lock and examine SCP-173 but Jake could
take offense to such language examining
might be the wrong word more accurately
they would just look at it because there
was nothing to examine there was nothing
to observe
SCP-173 was already understood Michael
Jordan doesn't take a microscope to the
ball every time he plans to dribble he
knows every detail of it by heart his
fingertips know the grooves his hand-eye
coordination knows how to control it his
right arms built in apt for physics
knows exactly how much force to put into
each shot and at what trajectory to aim
we are told to learn something new every
day but the truth is there comes a day
when the learning stops when we know all
that we will ever know and this felt
true to Jake they understood
SCP-173 there was nothing more for them
to see it was just concrete Reebok and
some spray paint that was it and that
was all that it would ever be there was
nothing to find nothing to determine
nothing for the researcher to research
their job was done but they kept having
to work it their identity no longer fit
but they kept having to put it on each
and every morning when Jake first got
there they collected samples of the
concrete some of the rebars some spray
paint they were determined to find
something worthy of research after four
weeks they'd gotten sick of getting no
replies from admin and they cracked the
locks on the filing cabinet finding the
research notes of all the previous
researchers all the legendary doctor's
notes turned out to be Doodles and
random to-do lists which had nothing to
do with the object after six weeks they
gave up on taking samples after eight
weeks they brought a Game Boy after 10
they started bringing in anything they
could to pass the time a yo-yo a
collection of short stories a packet of
hot sauce they felt bad throwing away a
piece of string to cut off circulation
to their index finger for no other
reason than to make sure they were still
a human relying on blood oh yes Jake's
skull was bored so very bored they
thought if anyone could bring the phrase
bored to death to fruition it would be
them these days they shuffled in and
waved at the guard and sat down at their
little control room where there was a
terminal which by the way didn't have an
internet connection and tried to stay
sane fast forward a few years and Jake
barely fit into his chair to clarify no
they did not purchase a new tiny chair
out of Fordham they got fat out of
boredom their life brought them no joy
and so what they couldn't get from
living they searched for in eating but
there was no fulfillment to be found at
the center of the Tootsie Pop Jake stood
with a grunt as the light came on and
the 3D class were escorted to the
control room with the mops and buckets
in tow thanks Jimmy was the only
conversation they had with the new
security staff the Old Guard had retired
sometime in the eighth year honestly Jay
couldn't even remember the d-class had
gotten older too most of them now
gray-haired but still assigned to the
project the security guard walked over
and thumbed towards the break room Hey
Jake I'm gonna get coffee if anything
happens seal the door you know the drill
just keep an eye on the DS Jake buzzed
the doors open and stood inside the door
frame keeping their eyes on the Statue
most of the time but but wandering over
the containment chamber a long time ago
they might have been concerned but the
d-classes they worked with weren't very
violent frankly they had worked with
these men long enough that they extended
a small measure of trust all them did
their jobs without complaining and never
had made a mistake in 10 years while the
years of repetition wore them out the
job itself didn't even feel like labor
they had perfected the art of the
staring contest they were confident and
they had reason to be as the years went
on although they collected no new data
on SCP-173 they did collect evidence
evidence that they were capable of
containing it while they learned nothing
new of importance about SCP-173 they
learned about themselves they learned
that they were a good crew and it was
because of this confidence even if
rightfully earned that success crumbled
when in a room with SCP-173 you have to
assume everything will go wrong because
anything can go wrong and eventually it
will and when that time comes you have
to be prepared procedure said Jake had
to have someone armed in the room with
any d-class Jake looked down at their
head double checked the pistol there
they knew how to use it but figured he
never would have to draw it the routine
cleaning began Claire Claire Claire it
was the same old same old until suddenly
it wasn't clear oh no I think I'm having
a snap what hey hey Nick are you snap oh
God no I don't want to snap Jake's eyes
shut up as the statue stood inches away
its green eyes stared directly into
their soul in their periphery Jay could
see the 3D class with their head turned
at odd angles Jake desperately reached
out for the Emergency containment button
on the wall they hadn't ever had to use
it and it was supposed to be easy to
find but of course it wasn't they were
called the manual saying move your hand
anywhere along the right hand wall the
button takes up most of the wall it will
seal off the containment chamber and
SCP-173 from breaching containment they
moved their hand exactly how their
memory of the manual instructor
but it wasn't there there was nothing to
press there was nothing to save them
Jake's hands grew desperate and their
eyes began to water just as they started
to close a last thought crossed their
mind move your hand anywhere along the
left hand wall the button takes up most
of the wall it will seal off the
containment chamber and SCP-173 from
breaching containment of course a
classic mix-up 50 50 chances never
favored the flustered their
fight-or-flight instincts were
contradicting each other was reaching
for button fighting or was it fighting
they were in their head deep in trenches
of overthinking finally they regained
their composure their hand darted out to
the left and they started to push down
on the button the red of the emergency
button filled their Vision as the green
eyes of SCP-173 slipped just barely out
of snap director Kinsley stood outside
of the meeting room a few minutes before
the weekly briefing in the site 2117
administrative wing for them do you
remember Jake's skull oh yeah I sure do
just got a report from 19. looks like
there was a breach and they bit it
Fordham waved off a few colleagues who
were about to enter the meeting room his
conversation with director Kinsley
wasn't over he went on to tell him that
he was just about to approve Jake
skull's transfer after all these years
Jake had been sending requests to leave
SCP-173 their wish was about to be
granted but instead they were reassigned
to the Grave what a cruel twist isn't it
that is of course if it were actually
true Fordham gave his patented smirk
just kidding the only researchers to
ever get out of that post needed friends
in very high places scroll to his
detriment did not so what exactly did
skold do to deserve this it is known
that those who are sent to a cp-173 have
made mistakes if you disrespect your
boss you might be reassigned to SCP-173
if you don't follow Foundation policy
you might reassigned to SCP-173 if you
leak information to the public you might
be reassigned to SCP-173 if you are Jake
scroll however it doesn't take quite as
much so I will pose the question once
more what horrible thing could Jake have
done could they have been plotting to
help an array of scps Escape could they
have been smuggling dangerous equipment
from the lab and selling it on the black
market could they have somehow been
responsible for every casualty and
Foundation history or could it have been
something much much smaller like
occasionally parking in their boss's
favorite spot on site 217 a lot you must
understand which doesn't have assigned
parking it had been getting slower the
longer the days weeks months and years
went on the more time it took to move
before long before the collapse it used
to move like lightning in the blink of a
human eye it could go from one side of a
room to the other it had moved with such
speed and it looked to have disappeared
from one place and reappeared in another
by the time the same human's eye
reopened there it would be standing
before them and as they realized that
they had to strain to keep their eyes
open and stare at it it would wait until
they inevitably had to Blink again that
was when it would strike but now its
movements were getting sluggish it had
been able to move around of its own
volition for some time after the
collapse unobserved and thus free for
the first time in a long while yet now
it was succumbing to the one thing it
couldn't move faster than the one thing
that makes dust of all things time a
sound suddenly and faintly but
undoubtedly caused by movement a human a
victim it turned to see the man enter
the room stopping still as his gaze fell
over it all it had to do was wait the
agent could barely believe his eyes the
second he'd spotted the sculpture he'd
instinctively froze into the spot rigid
with sheer Terror heart drumming against
his rib cage standing across the room
from it directly opposite he kept
himself as still as the concrete and
rebar statue was the agent knew that as
long as he looked at it it couldn't move
he just had to make sure he didn't so
much as blink or at least that's how it
used to work to his horror the agent
noticed that the arm of SCP-173 started
to slowly reach towards him but how how
had the sculpture an anomaly once
capable of moving only while unobserved
found a way to suddenly start reaching
this agent while for a start that is
something to do with the particular
Foundation operative who is looking at
SCP-173 and technically wasn't at the
same time let us start at the beginning
you see some time ago a former field
agent working at the SCP Foundation
suffered quite an unprecedented accident
let's call him Daryl a seemingly average
man in his 30s well as average as
someone working for the foundation can
be however one Mission would
unexpectedly change Daryl's life forever
turning him into
scp-451 it started as a straightforward
retrieval operation Daryl was instructed
to recover a dangerous anomalous
artifact however he ultimately failed
and was declared missing in action as a
result that is until he miraculously
resurfaced a month later at site 19 but
from Daryl's point of view the entire
Foundation facility looked like it had
been desert
corridors and Labs that had previously
been bustling hives of activity were now
unsettlingly empty scps seem to still be
in their containment Chambers but
without anyone watching or guarding them
as far as scp-451 knew he was the only
man still alive on Earth some anomalous
influence had left him with a unique
Affliction a permanently altered
perception Daryl was rendered incapable
of seeing other human beings it wasn't
just limited to his sight either he
couldn't hear anyone or even perceive
their existence any attempts the
foundation's researchers made to
communicate with scp-451 were
unsuccessful they could still see him
but it was like he was absent standing
just outside the real world and yet to
Daryl it was somehow worse than that
given the lack of people around him
being unable to see hear or interact
with anyone
scp-451 quickly adopted the belief that
by interacting with the anomalous
artifact he had single-handedly wiped
out the entire human race while this
wasn't true he had no way of knowing
that everyone else was still alive he
just couldn't perceive them the guilt
instilled in Daryl weighed heavily on
the agent's conscience he spent a lot of
time wandering the corridors of site 19
overwhelmed by his apparent isolation
convinced he'd single-handedly caused
the extinction of the human race but
what does scp-451 have to do with
SCP-173 how did Daryl go from being
unable to see and hear other humans to
staring down the sculpture well while
Daryl was suffering from his newly
altered perception something
catastrophic was unfolding in The Wider
world he could hardly interact with
anymore an end of the world scenario had
taken place and left barely any
survivors making the perceived
Extinction of humanity by scp-451 oddly
prophetic something had caused the human
race to actually die out and with nobody
around who could explain what had
happened the actual how and why were
forgotten to history and even if someone
had managed to survive
scp-451 would still be as oblivious to
their explanations as he was to the
disaster that claimed the lives of not
only the whole SCP Foundation but the
rest of the world too of course without
the foundation and its Personnel around
any longer to safeguard the rest of
humanity or even anything left of
humanity for them to protect things
quickly got even worse the various
contained scps soon found themselves
free to run amok whatever had wiped the
human race from existence left the world
mostly uninhabited and it didn't take
long for some of the more aggressive
anomalies to turn on each other with no
humans for them to prey on they had to
make do but while they [__] killed
they and died in the ruins of the world
one was left to roam Freer than it had
ever been
SCP-173 now that the sculpture was no
longer caged by the foundation it could
move around unobserved before it would
be frozen in place whenever Personnel
entered its cell to clean it every two
weeks constantly watching it to stop it
from moving but now there were no
Personnel after the human race had been
wiped out
SCP-173 set about bursting free from its
container it took quite some time using
its heavy concrete and rebar arms to
Dent the walls from within continually
pounding on the metal until it
eventually gave way bursting free
SCP-173 found itself in a world with
hardly anyone around to look at it and
that meant it could go anywhere it
wanted do anything it pleased so long as
none of the other surviving scps came
across it that did happen from time to
time of course and any of the more
humanoid anomalies that were capable of
sight would sometimes stumble upon the
sculpture but they had to bling some
time and when they did
SCP-173 would effortlessly zip over to
where they stood and break their necks
exercising its Newfound Freedom
SCP-173 moved unnoticed to the office of
Dr Alto cleff the infamously unhinged
Foundation researcher weapons fanatic
and specialist in decommissioning scps
clef like the rest of the human race was
nowhere to be found when the sculpture
burst into his office if it had the
capacity for emotions maybe it felt
angered even cheated to find that clef
was gone it had seemed to have come
seeking revenge for a number of years Dr
clef had been infatuated with SCP-173
were he still alive clef himself would
have described the anomalous statue as a
former flame someone he had a bond with
although he had no idea how one-sided
his feelings truly were the sculpture if
it could feel would have been
indifferent towards the crazed
researcher were it not for date night
clef had on a number of occasions
dressed as cp-173 in a black dress and a
blonde wig and shared romantic evenings
in its company it's never been known if
SCP-173 is just an object with anomalous
movement Properties or if the sculpture
is an actual living creature with
sentience but if it was then no doubt
being made to go on repeated dates with
Dr clef would have humiliated
SCP-173 and as it searched cleft's
office while I couldn't find the
loathsome researcher it did find a
certain black dress and wig that the
sculpture quickly crushed under the
weight of its heavy Stony arms it wasn't
Dr clef being smashed but it was enough
meanwhile scp-451 still remained
completely unaware that everyone else
was gone to him nothing had changed he
still couldn't perceive anyone not that
there was anyone around anyway he'd
witness a lot of Destruction unfurled by
the anomalous breaking their containment
the most didn't pay Daryl any mind ones
that did quickly found they couldn't
interact with him or cause the former
Foundation agent harm and quickly lost
interest in him that was an added
torturous part of scp-451's condition he
couldn't die a long time before the end
of the world scenario Daryl had found a
firearm belonging to another member of
foundation Personnel in the main break
room of Psych 19. as scp-451 tried to
fire the weapon the bullet ricocheted
off the wall and The Gunshot passed
directly through him the same bullet
mortally wounded another nearby member
of foundation staff and it was after
he'd accidentally injured this
unsuspecting researcher that scp-451
found he was brief able to interact with
them right as the researcher's life was
fading that was the last time he'd been
able to see anyone well any human anyway
but then he encountered
SCP-173 the pair of them came face to
face with each other in the ruins of a
foundation site by that point the
overwhelming loneliness of believing
himself to be Humanity's Soul Survivor
had already taken a bad toll on Daryl he
was losing himself every day getting
more and more overwhelmed by the
anomalous hell he was living
SCP-173 was caught for a moment when
scp-451 walked in on it stuck fast like
it had been whenever someone observed it
but as Daryl stared and tried not to
Blink the sculpture found itself still
able to move it could see scp-451 and he
could see it yet it could still move
somehow due to the way Daryl's
perception had been anomalously altered
it affected the way he saw the sculpture
it was almost like he was seeing it
without seeing it had been so long since
Humanity disappeared that the
sculpture's movements had been gradually
getting slower the rebar holding it
together had been rusting creaking more
as it bent and twisted its concrete
parts were starting to crumble away and
now despite being free it was struggling
just to reach an arm out to scp-451 to
kill him for his part scp-451 had been
forced to live out a painful existence
spending each and every day alone as
delirium had begun to sink its claws
into him Daryl had wished for one thing
some company and now he'd found it
misinterpreting scp-173's arm extending
towards him
scp-451 broke down crying and embraced
the sculpture his tears ran down the
anomalous statues decaying concrete body
the struts in its arms creaking as it
tried to reach for Daryl but the
sculpture was getting old too old to
kill as quick as it used to time and
loneliness two of the most painful
things to experience the side effect of
and yet while SCP-173 continued to
wither it was unknowingly helping
alleviate someone else's pain although
it could still move while scp-451 looked
at it Daryl didn't leave the sculpture
alone in his mind driven half mad by
being isolated for so long he genuinely
believed that SCP-173 and he were
friends the sculpture had spared him
after all
scp-451 had no idea what had happened to
the rest of the human race and the other
scps now loose on the world barely
acknowledged him but in the concrete and
rebar statue he found a friend
scp-451 followed a cp-173 as it shuffled
itself away not leaving its side
matching the slowed speed of its Stony
scraping movements as they wandered
together Daryl poured his heart out
about everything and anything glad to
have someone anyone to talk to even if
the sculpture couldn't reply again
nobody knows for sure if SCP-173 was an
object or a living creature but if it
was the latter then there's still no
telling how it perceived as cp-451 it
could have taken pity on him maybe
sympathizing with his plight and
begrudgingly alleviating his Solitude or
it might have found Daryl to be a
nuisance we'll never know and neither
would scp-451 as the years passed as
cp-173 continued to slow down and kept
withering portions of its concrete body
crumbled until they were little more
than dust the metal wired through the
sculpture rusted eventually coming to a
stop what was left of SCP-173 stopped
moving fixed to one spot where it would
stay forever still not realizing it had
perished
scp-451 sat beside it and kept talking
now go check out scp-096 versus SCP-173
and SCP-173 origin story how 173 got to
site 19 for more killer sculpture